polit veranstaltung die eben nicht mehr
duell sondern trier heißt und wir freuen
uns auf ein aufeinandertreffen von
annalena baerbock armin laschet und olaf
scholz vor dem auftrag austragungsort in
berlin adlershof da sind schon
unterstützer und fans aller drei und
natürlich berichterstatter aus aller
welt das interesse ist groß und wenn man
sich daran erinnert dass bei einer
ähnlichen veranstaltung vor vier jahren
mehr als 16 millionen vor dem fernseher
gesessen haben dann kann man erwarten
dass das auch heute ein hit wird in zwei
wochen ist bundestagswahl
manche wahlberechtigte haben schon per
briefwahl abgestimmt aber die
verbleibenden 14 tage bieten noch viele
gelegenheiten bisher unschlüssige zu
überzeugen
julius van de laar kampagnen und
strategieberater liegt für uns auf das
trio
laschet zuletzt kämpferischer die wende
jedoch bleibt bisher aus armin laschet
es hinten in den umfragen er muss
natürlich auf angriff spielen und auch
olaf scholz treiben gleichzeitig dafür
auch nicht zu politisch werden nicht zu
hart attackieren war das auch einfach
was ist was fernsehzuschauerinnen und
zuschauer auch ab turnt und sie
womöglich auch eben von armin laschet
weg treibt
muss mit angriffen rechnen ermittlungen
beim zoll die staatsanwaltschaft deshalb
im ministerium die aufgabe von olaf
scholz an diesem abend in diesem trio
ist einfach solide aufzutreten keine
fehler zu machen und vor allem nicht die
chance einer großen schlagzeile am
nächsten morgen eben auch zu liefern
dementsprechend wenn er die attacken
abwehren kann wenn er einfach nur solide
durch navigiert ich glaube dann wird das
nicht die große comeback store geben es
wird nicht wie der armin laschet hoch
geschrieben und er kann einfach so die
letzten zwei wochen auch ausspielen wer
bock sagt der berater müsse sich
entscheiden risiko oder nummer sicher
dementsprechend glaube ich muss sich
überlegen will ich hier wirklich die
grüne parteibasis das wirklich grüne
kern klientel ansprechen oder nutze ich
diese gelegenheit wo wirklich nochmal
fünf vielleicht sechs oder sieben
millionen leute nochmal auf diesen einen
abend schauen um nochmals neue themen
auf zu machen und vielleicht mich auch
nochmal deutlich attraktiver zu machen
über die eigene parteibasis hinaus
die tri l bühne ist bereitet wer wird
sie am besten für sich nutzen und
am schauplatz des geschehens begrüße ich
erhard scherfer ihrer meinung nach
worauf kommt es heute für wen an
tja das ist die ganz zentrale frage
thomas bader es geht natürlich darum
dass hier alle sich noch mal bemerkbar
machen dass sie nochmal zeigen und
herausstreichen können wofür sie
eigentlich stehen und es geht
insbesondere für den kanzlerkandidaten
von cdu/csu darum nochmal deutlich zu
machen dass er angreifen kann und will
dass er möglicherweise die beiden
anderen mit kandidierenden auch noch mal
in die bedrängnis bringen kann ob ihm
das gelingen wird das werden wir in
kürze sehen aber das ist zumindest das
was man ihm im vorfeld ja geraten hat
wir erinnern uns an die äußerung und
setzte die aus der csu gekommen sind
dass das entscheidende wochenende sei
dieses hier nicht nur mit dem
csu-parteitag der hat er ja zumindest
nach innen hinein armin laschet ja
durchaus gewirkt und gezeigt dass er
wieder auch angreifen kann aber heute
muss er dann noch mal gegen die beiden
anderen antreten und wie die reagieren
werden das werden wir schauen wir
vermuten dass im urlaub scholz ein
bisschen lebendiger vielleicht auftritt
also dass bei dem ersten trainer gemacht
hat vor 14 tagen und annalena baerbock
hat ja seitdem es einigermaßen klar zu
sein scheint dass sie nicht kanzlerin
werden kann zumindest wenn man sich die
umfrageergebnisse anguckt doch deutlich
entspannter aufgetreten in diversen
diskussionen und bei auftreten und
insofern könnte das ganze auch weil es
so angelegt dass also alles in allem
eine sehr muntere angelegenheit werden
welche stimmung ist nicht kurz vor
diesem trio vor und hinter den kulissen
zu spüren was denken denn die die schon
da sind über diese veranstaltung
sie sind tatsächlich und da hat mich
doch ein bisschen überrascht ich habe
mit der einen und dem anderen gesprochen
von einer guten halben stunde und
darüber hinaus das sind doch einige
wirklich erfahrene politikerinnen
durchaus aufgeregt vor dieser
veranstaltung hier weil sie sagen es ist
eben ein teil dieses wahlkampfs und ein
ganz zentraler und in deswegen sind wir
durchaus gespannt wie das ganze hier
vonstatten geht deswegen ist sein
durchaus eine grundspannung wir zu
spüren auch bei den beteiligten auch bei
den veranstaltern es sind übrigens mehr
menschen hier in diesem zelt auf dem
studiogelände in berlin adlershof als
das im moment sich vermittelt wir zeigen
ihm ein klein wenig was hier in diesem
zelt noch zu entdecken ist es gibt hier
mit diverse getränkestände und
versorgungsstände und städtischen team
allermeisten besucher dieser
veranstaltung die nachher auf den
stuhlreihen hinter mir sitzen werden die
sind noch draußen im hof fängt gibt es
noch viele gelegenheiten sich zu
unterhalten und auch noch mal
auszutauschen aber die anspannung bei
denen die verantwortlich sind
beispielsweise generalsekretäre
bundesgeschäftsführer
bundesgeschäftsführer die ist auch
deutlich zu spüren haben denn die drei
ihre vertrauten mitgebracht also sind so
genannte spin doktoren da die gleich
zitate deuten und verbreiten
ja davon gehen wir ganz fest aus hat
schon gesagt ihr generalsekretär und
bundesgeschäftsführer sind da natürlich
sind auch enge mitarbeiter da auch
pressesprecher sind hier und
pressesprecherinnen sind hier reichlich
vertreten bei dieser veranstaltung und
die werden natürlich unmittelbar nach
ende des tri ace wenn sich alle anfragen
ihre meinung zu bilden über das was sie
da gesehen haben natürlich auch mit
ihren deutungen hier wieder
unterwegs sein das ist gar keine frage
vielleicht können wir noch ein bisschen
darauf verwenden dass alle drei parteien
die hier kanzlerkandidatin
beziehungsweise kandidaten ins rennen
geschickt haben relativ viel prominenz
aufgeboten haben beispielsweise von der
union ist das halbe kompetenzteam
beispielsweise hier etwa dann außerdem
ministerien carlitscheck auch die
stellvertretende parteivorsitzende brea
habe ich gesehen die spd ist vertreten
mit der parteivorsitzenden der
generalsekretär natürlich auch dann ist
balu dreier da die ministerpräsidentin
von rheinland pfalz und von den grünen
haben wir gesehen beispielsweise die
fraktionsvorsitzende katrin göring
eckardt wochen hatte künast
a300 bütikofer sind wir hier schon
begegnet also es ist doch einiges
aufgeboten worden an parteiprominenz um
dann natürlich auch in diesen deutung
prozess den ist hier im anschluss dann
geben wird auch noch ein klein wenig
einzugreifen lassen sie uns zum schluss
kurz über den ablauf sprechen welche
genauen regeln gibt es
die sind relativ ähnlich zu dem tri l
dass wir vor 14 tagen auch bei rtl
gesehen haben diesmal moderieren ja
maybrit illner und oliver coeur ist soll
wohl wenn man das richtig deutet aus den
ankündigungen etwas mehr streitgespräch
geben zwischen den drei kandidierenden
also sie sollen auch mehr untereinander
kommunizieren und sicher austauschen und
argumentieren können als das vor 14
tagen der fall gewesen ist aber
ansonsten sind bestimmte themenblöcke
festgelegt werden über die gesprochen
werden soll auch müssen natürlich darauf
geachtet werden dass hier alle ungefähr
die gleiche zeit der redezeit haben mit
abweichungen gönnt man sich oder
genehmigt man sich in anführungszeichen
eine minute zwischen den rednern und
alle drei werden dann auch am ende der
industriell sich dann noch mal jeweils
eine minute im schlussfeld man zu äußern
dürfen vielen dank erhard scherfer und
ich sag bis später denn wir sind ja auch
noch zur analyse verabredet bis dann
es ist das zweite derartige
aufeinandertreffen und viele sagen jetzt
sei das entscheidende bei mir im studio
begrüße den politikwissenschaftler
professor volker kronenberg guten abend
gute nacht erwartet wie war das nach dem
ersten werk kam da besonders gut weg und
wer weniger gut
naja in der selbstwahrnehmung hat haben
frau berbalk scholz und laschet
natürlich gesagt dass sie jeweils
diejenigen waren die vorne lagen dann
hat es ja nach wahl oder umfragen
gegeben nach der veranstaltung und da
kristallisierte sich so ein stück weit
raus erst holzer berbalk denn da steht
aber und das große aber man muss
natürlich vorsichtig sein
repräsentatives das eine und dann gibt
es natürlich auch immer eine marge von 3
bis 5 insofern sie lagen alle dicht
beieinander ich würde sagen das ergebnis
dieser ersten runde war sie sind alle
drei im rennen ist es keine oder keine
wirklich abgefallen aber das was er
gerade gesagt hat würde ich
unterstreichen heute in der mitte dieses
mittlere öffentlich-rechtliche tree l
das wird sicherlich die meiste
aufmerksamkeit finden dass drittes
unmittelbar kurz vor der wahl jetzt geht
es darum denn es sind dann noch zwei
wochen beim ersten trial so meine
wahrnehmung hat das in der bevölkerung
noch einmal die aufmerksamkeit auch auf
die namen der wahl erhöht und heute ist
sicherlich so eine punktlandung zwei
wochen vor der wahl konzentriertes
verfolgen heute geht es darum welche
themen kamen denn beim ersten teil ihrer
meinung nach zu kurz
ich glaube dass ein wichtiges thema was
sich ja alle auf die fahne schreiben
digitalisierung nicht wirklich
erschöpfend behandelt wurde oder das
andere thema bezahlbares wohnen wohnraum
dann sicherlich auch so etwas wie wie
extremismus oder oder andere themen wie
wird man sicherlich heute nochmals
vertiefen plus natürlich die reaktionen
auf die jüngsten einlassungen wir haben
ja auch das klang gerade an ich will das
aufgreifen einen deutlich
angriffslustigere armin laschet in den
letzten tagen gerade jetzt auf dem
parteitag der csu erlebt stichwort die
spd konnte nie mit geld umgehen oder sie
lagen historisch immer falsch bei finanz
und wirtschaftspolitischen themen
interessant ist ja nicht dass er hier
mehr angreift und zu spitz interessant
ist ja dass sich die spd sozusagen jetzt
so empört und diesen fehdehandschuh
quasi aufgreift ich frage die proben das
also heute herr scholz und andere eben
sehr stark auf das thema finanzen gehen
werden und herr bade es wird sicherlich
heute ohnehin mehr angriffslust
erkennbar seien bei allen dreien okay
also mehr angriffslust ist schon mal
ganz gut da wird spannender welche
themen sind denn heute inhaltlich die
wichtigsten eben über die sachthemen wie
bezahlbares wohnen oder digitalisierung
oder anderes mehr glaube ich wird es
jetzt zwei wochen vor der wahl jenseits
der einzelthemen darum gehen dass man
sozusagen als kandidatin als kandidat
den gesamtentwurf sozusagen präsentiert
das heißt also frau peer bork einerseits
das klima aber auf der anderen seite
eben was wollen denn die grünen so sie
denn die regierungsverantwortung
übernehmen würden in den nächsten vier
jahren sozusagen als als verbindendes
als als rote linie präsentieren und das
werden sicherlich herr laschet unter
scholz auch verdeutlichen müssen das
heißt nicht nur immer die
gemeinsamkeiten also alle wollen mehr
klima- und alle wollen mehr
digitalisierung das wissen alle aber wo
unterscheiden sie sich genau und was ist
sozusagen der gesamtentwurf ich habe
gerade gesagt zwei wochen vor der wahl
jetzt tut sich noch was obwohl der
anteil der briefwähler interessanter
weil sie ja schon sehr sehr hoch ist und
auch der anteil derer die angeblich
schon 70 prozent schon entschieden sind
was sie wählen das hat es in der
vergangenheit so nicht gegeben aber alle
drei wissen auch heute können sie
nochmal mobilisieren und das machen sie
nicht mit einzelthemen sondern mit einem
überzeugenden auftritten und einem
gesamtentwurf und wer geht heute mit
mehr rückenwind ins rennen laschet nach
dem csu-parteitag oder scholz wegen der
guten umfragewerte
naja also scholz liegt natürlich vorne
weiß aber auch wie volatil wie flüchtig
ein stückweit umfragen sind und der darf
natürlich nicht als verteidiger
sozusagen ihr auftreten das ist er ja
gar nicht erst genauso kandidat die
lasche aber laschet weiß auch er hatte
viel mehr gegenwind als rückenwind jetzt
hatte er sozusagen aus den reihen der
csu das heißt er muss natürlich heute
angreifen auf der anderen seite darf
natürlich stolz auch nicht zu präsidial
schon weil das schätzen die wählerinnen
und wähler natürlich auch nicht und frau
berben ja im grunde muss sie daran
anknüpfen was sie im ersten
viel geleistet hat eben deutlich zu
machen ja sie kann auch überzeugen auch
wenn letztendlich jeder im grunde auch
spürt sie kämpft jetzt nicht mehr um den
ersten platz aber auf um augen hören das
ist ihnen erst mal höhere sagen also vor
ein paar wochen hätte sie noch auf sieg
gespielt hätte sie hätte sie aber ich
weiß natürlich auch an das hat
selbstkritisch eingeräumt dass da
natürlich gravierende fehler geschehen
sind aber auf der anderen seite sie ist
dabei und das ist ja für die grünen
erinnern wir uns an profil jahren acht
jahren zwölf jahren dass die grünen
jetzt quasi selbstverständlich arbeitet
das ist ja schon ein sieg kann sich
solche normalerweise duelle diesmal tree
elle die haben ja schon verrückte regeln
und dinge auf die man beachten muss
erinnern wir uns an die geschichte
solcher fernsehdebatten es kommt
natürlich aus amerika ganz klar das
erste glaube ich war zwischen nixon und
kenne die nächsten rat verloren weil er
nicht ausgeschlafen war weil er nicht
rasiert war und weil er da ein bisschen
müde rumsas und kennedy hat einfach
gestrahlt und hat gesiegt und auf die
uhr geschaut hat und das ist genau das
was wir sagen die kandidatinnen dürfen
nie auf die uhr schauen nicht
gelangweilt wirken nicht genervt das ist
tatsächlich ganz ganz spannend und was
natürlich nicht das aufgreifen darf man
kann ganz viel vorbereitet man ganz kann
ganz viel planen aber
überraschungsmoment haben diesen 90
minuten immerhin sich professor volker
kronenberg vielen dank für diese erste
analyse für diesen ersten einblick und
werden anschließend ausreichend zeit
darüber zu sprechen und jetzt schauen
wir uns mit ihnen gemeinsam das tri l an
und als kleiner bonus tracks gibt auch
mit gebärde damit wirklich alle die
chance haben das mitzuerleben
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer herzlich
willkommen zum dreikampf der
spitzenkandidaten bei ard und zdf einen
schönen guten abend in den nächsten 95
minuten wollen wir zentrale probleme
dieses landes besprechen und die frage
stellen wie diese drei die probleme
lösen wollen als kanzlerin oder als
kanzler guten abend annalena baerbock
guten armin laschet und einen guten
abend olaf scholz wir moderatoren sind
gespannt wir werden darauf achten dass
die rede anteile unter ihnen
einigermaßen fair verteilt sind und wir
sagen auch noch dass alle menschen hier
in diesem studio negativ getestet oder
geimpft sind und schon geht's los genau
und zwar mit der ersten frage an armin
laschet nach allen umfragen liegen sie
im augenblick hinter der spd jetzt
werden sie dafür kämpfen in den nächsten
14 tagen als erster ins ziel zu kommen
aber wenn das nicht gelingen sollte
würden sie auch als juniorpartner in
eine regierung scholz eintreten also als
erstes wollen wir jetzt die nächsten
wochen kämpfen das ist das ziel das ist
ja auch die idee dieses tri ace dass die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer draußen
sich noch einmal ein bild verschaffen
können wer steht für welche position und
das ist das was wir jetzt für unter und
die frage war aber ob sie in regierungs
scholz einzig aber nicht beantwortet wie
sie gesehen haben sondern wir sind nicht
bei regierungsbildungen sondern wir sind
beim werben um den richtigen weg für
unser land was steht jetzt an und ich
finde wir haben nach der wahl noch so
viel zeit zu sehen wer mit wem sie
koaliert jetzt ist die zeit eigene
argumente zu nennen und das will ich
heute die zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
würde es aber trotzdem interessieren und
ich kann sie nicht zwingen zu antworten
aber den zuschauerinnen und zuschauern
sagen sie wollen die frage nicht
beantworten also eines ist klar für uns
wir werden auf keinen fall mit der
linken koalieren wir werden auf keinen
fall mit der fdp koalieren wir werden
mit denen nicht mal reden wir werden
nicht kooperieren und demokraten
untereinander müssen nach der wahl reden
und wir kämpfen um platz eins und damit
sind wir bei annalena baerbock sie
merken schon wir fragen nach politischen
vorlieben und nach politischen grenzen
sie haben schon angekündigt dass sie
gerne mit olaf scholz eine
regierungsbündnis eingehen indem für rot
grün reicht es momentan nicht tendieren
sie eher zur fdp oder tendieren sie zu
den linken bei der fdp wäre klar dass
sie eigentlich alle sozialen punkte
ihres programms plus klimaschutz nicht
gut durchsetzen können erst meinen
schönen guten abend so ich tendiere
derzeit zu keiner der beiden varianten
sondern ich kämpfe mit voller
leidenschaft für den echten aufbruch die
wahl die jetzt hier an steht in knapp
zwei wochen ist machen wir weiter so der
großen koalition oder schaffen wir in
echten aufbruch und der geht nur mit
starken grünen der geht nur mit grün in
führender rolle und dafür kämpfe ich
gerade die großen themen klimaschutz
digitalisierungen stehen das war es wo
wir jetzt eine veränderung im land
stehen die grünen gerade nicht so gut da
es gab mal ein schwarz grünes projekt
daran sei erinnert und beide parteien
haben momentan zu kämpfen noch mal die
frage es geht nur ein dreier bündnis
würden sie sagen mit der linkspartei
können wir viele unserer punkte von den
mieten bis zum klimaschutz viel besser
umsetzen sie haben nicht diesen bündnis
ausschluss partei vertrag des bündnis
aus 2013 ein bündnis paragrafen
parteitagsbeschluss abgeschlossen wie
die spd und sagen trotzdem dass sie sich
das mit der linken vorstellen können
oder könnten sie sich nicht mit der
linken ich habe mich in den letzten
tagen dazu sehr klar geäußert dass wir
eine wirkliche veränderung brauchen eine
veränderung bedeutet das ding auch
wirklich anders gemacht werden deswegen
kämpfe ich auch wenn uns ein paar
prozentpunkte noch nach oben fehlen für
eine führung unter einer grünen
regierung wir haben die meisten
schnittmengen gerade missionaren links
von sozialen bereich mit der spd mit der
linkspartei auch das habe ich ja
mehrfach deutlich gemacht ich bin von
herzen pro europäerin ich bin davon
überzeugt die nächste bundesregierung
muss eine aktive außenpolitik betreiben
sich nicht wegducken und die linke hat
mit der letzten entscheidung auch mit
blick auf afghanistan deutlich gemacht
dass sie diese internationale
verantwortung nicht tragen will aber wir
haben in den letzten jahren auch in
unserem land der gesehen wie
brandgefährliches ist wenn demokratische
parteien nicht miteinander reden und
deswegen sage ich hier klar und deutlich
wir reden mit allen demokratischen
parteien die linke ist die linke eine
demokratische partei oder ist sie halb
demokratische karriere sie für dieses
land genauso gefährlich wie die afg auf
gar keinen fall und diese gleichsetzung
von afg mit linker halte ich für
brandgefährlich vor allen dingen weil
man dann absolut verharmlost dass die
fdp nicht auf dem boden des
grundgesetzes steht wir erleben dass
immer wieder im deutschen bundestag wir
koalieren mit der linken in einigen
bundesländern auch deswegen hat
selbstverständlich es ist eine
demokratische partei aber wir haben in
der außenpolitik wir haben auch mit
blick auf die innenpolitik innere
sicherheit verfassungsschutz große
differenzen auch mit der linken aber
noch mal wir sind jetzt kurz vor
leider fällt schon der studios haben
will will ihn kurz vor der bundesbank
alles noch wie es gerade hier rumpelt im
studio so spannend wird diese
bundestagswahl ich glaube es war in den
letzten jahrzehnten noch nie so spannend
wir hatten das schon mal als damals rot
grün gewählt worden ist bei 2002 da war
es auch bis zur letzten woche reichte es
eigentlich nicht mehr für dieses
zweierbündnis und deswegen gebe ich
jetzt alles weil ich bin zutiefst davon
überzeugt deutschland kann mehr und wir
brauchen jetzt den aufbruch herr scholz
sie koalieren auch in mehreren
bundesländern mit der linken warum
schließen sie aber eine koalition mit
der linken auf bundesebene wo ist wie
frau berbalk hat es angesprochen ja um
andere themen geht auch um aussenpolitik
ein solches bündnis dort nicht auf naja
ich meinen wir leben ja jetzt immer
absurdere theateraufführung vor kurzem
wurde lindner aufgefordert
auszuschließen dass er mit der spd und
den grünen koaliert das hat irgendwie
vielleicht deutlich gemacht dass wir auf
dem boden der dinge bleiben sollen die
bürgerinnen und bürger entscheiden wie
die wahl ausgeht ich werbe um ein sehr
sehr starkes mandat für die spd das
finde ich wichtig das gibt die grundlage
dafür dass man eine gute regierung
bilden kann und all die grundsätze
verfolgen die mir wichtig sind und das
ist klar wer in deutschland regieren
will muss klare positionen haben er muss
sich bekennen zur transatlantischen
zusammenarbeit da muss klar sagen dass
die nato für unsere sicherheit
unverzichtbar ist und dass wir unsere
verpflichtungen im bündnis erfüllen
müssen da muss sich klar zu einer
starken souverän europäischen union
bekennen und das will ich auch sagen da
gehört natürlich gerade auch jetzt wo
die zeiten schwierig sind will ich das
sagen zu dass man auch in der lage sein
muss entscheidung zu treffen die zum
beispiel bedeuten dass deutsche soldaten
an dann ländern zum beispiel im rahmen
eines eu mandats im rahmen eines mandats
der vereinten nationen oder der nato
tätig sind dass hier auch weiter sind
sogar aber themen mit denen sie über die
mit der linken sprechen würden ich bin
klar in den grundsätzen jeder der mich
kennt weiß was er kriegt und ich werde
mich entlang dieser grundsätze verhalten
und deshalb ist es jetzt erst mal
wichtig dass die bürgerinnen bürger ihre
entscheidung treffen und die
möglichkeiten nutzen die sie damit haben
umso besser dass man dafür die spd
ausfällt umso mehr möglich machen dass
sich der nächste regierungschef werde
umso besser wird es auch gelingen eine
gute regierung zu schaffen habe ich zu
der frage vielleicht nur kurz sagen das
ist ein wenig unredlich herr scholz zu
sagen das entscheiden die bürgerinnen
und bürger ja die bürgerinnen und bürger
werden ein wahlergebnis uns bescheren
danach stehen wir in der verantwortung
zu sagen was bilden wir für eine
regierung für deutschland und man muss
ihnen die frage gar nicht stellen ob sie
mit der linken koalieren würden weil sie
haben sie ja schon beantwortet sie
schließen das nicht aus wir haben die
bundestagsdebatte diese woche erlebt
herr bartsch von der linken hat gesagt
ihr müsst doch bei uns sein lieber die
linke als christian lindner in ihren
programmen sind sie in vielem ähneln
nicht mehr steuererhöhungen und bei
vielem anderen mehr und in ihrer
fraktion war zu sehen dass viele
zustimmend genickt haben manche sogar
geklatscht haben und deshalb muss jedem
klar sein wenn es eine rechnerische
mehrheit gibt selbst wenn sie auf platz
zwei liegen als partei werden sie eine
koalition mit den linken machen das und
deshalb glauben die bürgerinnen und
bürger ihnen das nur wenn sie klipp und
klar sagen jemand der den
verfassungsschutz abschaffen will erster
nato raus will selbst wenn der nachher
auf einem papier zugestehen würde ja ich
bin vielleicht doch für eine reformierte
nato sie müssen klarheit haben weil die
bürgerinnen und bürger die linke nicht
in einer bundesregierung haben will dazu
waren sie auch heute nicht bereit und
deshalb ist es schon mal eine klare
aussage von ihnen am heutigen abend mir
riecht ein bisschen daran zu sagen dass
ja die absurden dinge jedoch schon
deutlich geworden sind ich habe eben
darauf verwiesen dass herr söder
geforderte lindner soll das bündnis mit
uns beiden ausschließen und ich habe in
der frage der außen und
sicherheitspolitik genauso wie vor wir
haben mehr gemeinsamkeiten mit der fdp
als mit der partei über die sie jetzt
gesprochen haben aber was nicht
funktioniert ist dass man die bürgern
und bürger praktisch nicht mehr
beteiligt an den entscheiden und wenn es
nach einigen gegangen wäre dann wäre
schon vor ein paar monaten klar gewesen
wie die bundestagswahl ausgegangen wäre
man hätte sich nur noch über das
hinterher unterhalten müssen aber
tatsächlich ist das doch ein ganz großer
demokratischer moment ist es der tag der
bürgerinnen und bürger der 26 september
die entscheiden wer der nächste kanzler
wird indem sie ihr kreuz bei der partei
machen die ihn stellen soll aber das ist
auch das forum ist die frage der bürger
und was man mit ihnen erwartet als
kabinett sie haben kein zukunftsteam
vorgestellt sie haben kein
schattenkabinett vorgestellt sie halten
saskia esken für ministrabel unterliegt
die frage auf dem tableau wenn man olaf
scholz wählt bekommt man dann saskia
esken als ministerin man bekommt dann
olaf scholz als bundeskanzler und das
führt auch dazu dass eine regierung
gebildet wird die diesen grundsätzen
entspricht ich will mal ein bisschen
dafür werben dass irgendjemand von ihren
kollegen vielleicht auch einer von ihnen
beiden sie oder sie mal ein buch
lustiges buch schreibt über die
mitglieder von schattenkabinett die nix
geworden sind das ist ziemlich ziemlich
lange her und ehrlicherweise für das ja
auch dazu dass man dann ab lenkt von den
eigentlichen politischen debatten ich
jedenfalls werde ein kabinett
zusammenstellen das zur hälfte aus
männern und frauen besteht das aus
lauter männern und frauen besteht die
die sache auch gut können und die
zueinander passen und eine gute
regierung für unser land zustande
bringen wollte es ist alles auf sie
zugeschnitten in diesem wahlkampf auf
den spitzenkandidaten olaf scholz wie
gefährlich könnte dann ihre partei und
dem erfolg ihrer partei werden dass es
in ihrem ministerium im
finanzministerium eine razzia gegeben
hat die untersuchung die dort gemacht
werden sind von einer osnabrücker
behörde weil sie verdacht haben dass
möglicherweise in köln 1 bei mitarbeiter
bei der dortigen behörde nicht richtig
gearbeitet hätten die sind zur
unterstützung dieser erkenntnisgewinne
durchgeführt worden und das hat gar
nichts mit den ministerien zu tun wo das
stattgefunden hat die haben aber alles
gemacht was in dieser frage notwendig
ist wenn ich das hier bei der
gelegenheit einmal sagen darf als ich
bundesminister wurde im märz 2008
zehnter war gerade von bundesminister
schäuble organisiert worden dass défago
die financial intelligence unit drüber
geht zur toll dass dort die arbeit
geleistet wird die mitunter auf erfolge
schwarzer waren auch mehr mitarbeiter
die mit aufklärung von all den dingen
verbunden ist mit dem
terrorismusfinanzierung und all
diejenigen die dazugehören
und dann habe ich eine behörde
übernommen mit knapp 160 mitarbeitern
die jetzt fast 500 hat die dem es 700
mitarbeiter haben wird ich habe dafür
gesorgt dass sie eine moderne it bekommt
eine neue leitung dafür gesorgt dass mit
den länderministerien kriterien
gemeinsam entwickelt werden was
ausgesucht werden soll und wir haben
alle dazu eingeladen dass sie möglichst
viele meldungen machen dass meldung
aufkommen ist gestiegen von knapp 50.000
auf jetzt fast 150000 das wird auch
weiter steigen schon seinerzeit
intelligenten anderen kandidaten ob sie
die ihnen das abnehmen dass sie damit
mir selbst zu tun haben aber vielleicht
lassen sie mich das mal sagen wir setzen
sogar künstliche intelligenz ein wir
haben jetzt eine unternehmensberatung
beauftragt und diesen ganzen großen
aufbau und modernisierungsprozess einer
vorher ganz klein behörde zu
organisieren zu ende zu bringen und zu
voranzubringen und ich glaube dass das
wirklich ein ganz beeindruckende
leistung das halte ich dass auch eine
ganze reihe leistung also es ist
es ist schon ein wunder wie sie selbst
in diesem fall wenn eine
staatsanwaltschaft in ihr ministerium
kommt und untersuchungen durchführt eine
solche schönrederei an den tag legen
können sie haben die aufsicht über
geldwäsche sie haben diese institution
wir haben übrigens in unserem
wahlprogramm drin weil wir diese
defizite kannten diese institution ins
bundeskriminalamt zu integrieren und
nicht da wo sie jetzt ist und sie sagen
wir haben immer mehr mitarbeiter wird
aber immer weniger aufgeklärt und es
wird so wenig bei der geldwäsche
aufgeklärt dass ein staatsanwalt sagt
ich brauche hier weitere informationen
und dann ein richter verfügt dass eine
solche durchsuchen stattfinden kann und
deshalb per scholz war das unangemessen
dass sie abfällig über die justiz
geredet haben das ist unangemessen das
machen populistin in anderen ländern
wenn die kommen müssen sie sagen hier
ich lege alles offen und denen nicht
vorschreiben wie sie zur arbeit nahm und
wenn es der eine fall jetzt wäre wo sie
keine verantwortung übernehmen wollen
für den nachgeordneten bereich den sie
haben ist das ja nicht der erste fall
bei wirecard habe millionen klein
anlieger viel viel geld verloren weil
sie nicht die aufsicht richtig
ausgerichtet haben die das hätte
überprüfen müssen dafür tragen sie
verantwortung ich sie persönlich weil
sie jeden tag da am schreibtisch sitzen
und aufsicht üben aber als minister
haben sie wie jeder andere fachminister
auch dafür zu sorgen dass die
aufsichtsbehörde die es gibt ihren job
macht und wenn nicht haben sie
einzugreifen und wenn sie dazu nicht in
der lage sind also ich sage ihnen wenn
mein finanzminister so aber würde wie
sie hätten wir ein ernstes problem
und der dritte punkt comex da haben
kriminelle geschäfte dazu geführt dass
manche sich zweifach vom staat haben
geld erstatten lassen das ist ein unding
man muss nicht steuern erhöhen man muss
erstmal das geld was da wäre reinholen
und da haben sie in hamburg darauf
verzichtet dieses geld obwohl wolfgang
schäuble sie damals gewarnt hat dass
eine verjährungsfrist eintritt dieses
geld hinein zu holen jetzt wird darüber
gestritten ob sie den bankier getroffen
haben oder nicht kann ich nicht
beurteilen soll der
untersuchungsausschuss klären aber dass
sie an einem punkt einfach mal
verantwortung übernehmen so wie sie es
theoretisch bei dem amt das sie
anstreben machen müssten das kann man
von ihnen erwarten auch als
bundesminister der finanzen frau berg
machen sie sich diese vorwürfe auch zu
eigen
also ich kann jetzt in
staatsanwaltschaftliche ermittlungen
kann man von außen dich sagen was
richtig oder falsch ist dass dafür haben
wir die justiz die das überprüft da
haben wir ein klares rechtssystem wie
das vonstatten geht und was für mich
zentrales ist gerade in der situation wo
wir ja nach der korona pandemie in einer
lage sind dass wir viele viele
investitionen in die zukunft machen dass
wir viel viel geld brauchen und eines
der größten probleme auch mit blick auf
den staatshaushalt ist dass dem staat
rund 50 milliarden euro jährlich durch
steuerbetrug durch geldwäsche durch
kriminelle aktivitäten durch die lappen
gehen und jederzeit redlich seine
steuern in unserem land der buchladen
der kleine unternehmer die pflegekraft
und dass das thema steuer betrug
geldwäsche nicht in den letzten jahren
absolute priorität hat das fing schon an
bei der cdu sie haben dann ja gesagt sie
haben aufgestockt an personal
aufgestockt aber die drei
untergeordneten behörden des bundes
finanzamt überall hat es heftige
probleme gegeben dass fehlinformation
dass die fragen von kriminellen
tätigkeit nicht an die
staatsanwaltschaft weitergegeben wurden
sind und was für mich zentral ist es gab
ja aus dem deutschen bundestag das ist
das herzstück unserer demokratie das
parlament dann immer wieder nachfragen
sollte nicht noch einmal personal
eingestellt werden meine fraktion hat
das gefragt da hat ihr haus dann vor
einigen monaten noch gesagt nee braucht
aber nicht jetzt sehen wir
offensichtlich hat es ein großes problem
gegeben
ich frage mich ehrlich gesagt warum auch
mit blick auf diese offene frage mit der
warburg-bank das protokoll des
finanzausschusses von ihrem hause
blockiert wird dass es nicht
veröffentlicht wird oder in front of the
chicks und den grünen das ist ihr
potenzieller koalitionspartner herr
scholz sie sind dran schönen dank also
die erste aussage die hier machen möchte
ist das ja man sieht wie ein bisschen
dinge verdreht werden und zwar auch in
dem man ganz bewusst verdreht herr
laschet das müssen sie sich vorwerfen
lassen sehr klar es hat keine
untersuchung gegeben beim
bundesministerium der finanzen
es ist nicht so dass die
staatsanwaltschaft aus osnabrück
irgendwelche fragen hat bei der
ermittlung gegen dieses ministerium oder
gegen das justizministerium diesem
falschen eindruck haben sie mit absicht
erweckt er hat eine durchsuchung in
ihrem hobby haben einen absichtlich hat
anni haben laschet sie haben absichtlich
einen falschen eindruck erweckt und das
machen sie aus nicht guten gründen
deshalb darf er
sein traumhaus durchsucht worden oder
nicht jakub das so an ihrer frage merkt
man wie sehr sie unehrlich sind und das
ist etwas sehr unserem hause die
staatsanwalt kleine pause war die
startseite ist doch ein guter drehen die
staatsanwaltschaft hat eine untersuchung
in köln und für die untersuchung die sie
dort macht braucht sie auskünfte sie hat
keine untersuchung die im hinblick auf
dieses ministerium und weil sie das so
darstellen wecken sie einen falschen
eindruck packen völlig beiseite dass der
größte modernisierungs und aufbauprozess
dieser behörde stattgefunden knapp drei
jahren in denen ich minister bin und
packen noch ein paar andere unwahrheiten
dazu zum beispiel die dass bei wirecard
nicht die notwendigen maßnahmen auf den
weg gebracht worden sind wir haben dafür
gesorgt nachdem die wirtschaftsprüfer
jahrelang geprüft haben und nichts
rausgekriegt haben das jetzt eine
leistungsfähige gesetzesänderung
stattgefunden hat die dazu führt dass
wirtschaftsprüfer häufiger wechseln
müssen wir haben dafür gesorgt dass
prüfung und beratung getrennt werden wir
haben dafür gesorgt dass jetzt die
aufsichtsbehörde viel mehr macht hat als
sie viele viele jahre in deutschland
hatte und die möglichkeiten hat zu
handeln schnell
schon drei jahre zuvor auch
berichterstattung und journalistische
recherche die das nach wie es vielleicht
können wir es zusammenfassen ganz kurz
herr scholz wie dramatisch oder wie
schwer ist es wenn ausgerechnet ein
sozialdemokrat die beispiele sind
genannt comics vorjahr card und jetzt
diese razzia den anderen kennt lässt
dass er eben der finanzkriminalität und
ihrer bekämpfung
die aufgaben einfach nicht so ernst
nimmt oder lachs mit ihnen umgeht was
soll das beim steuerzahler auslösen wenn
er sie da agieren sie ganz einfach dass
er guckt was gemacht worden ist und die
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler sind
ja sehr klar so etwas wie den großen
aufbau der behörde über die wm
gesprochen hat es in dieser zeit
nirgendwo sonst gegeben das gleiche gilt
für die dramatischen entscheidenden
veränderung durch durchgesetzt hat bei
der wirtschaftsprüfung in deutschland
für die großen kapitalgesellschaften und
alle wissen dass sie an den
verschiedenen vorwürfen sich niemals
herausgestellt hat dass was dran ist und
das ist glaube ich auch ganz wichtig ich
habe das getan was zu tun ist wenn man
ein amt hat es gibt viele kriminelle die
straftaten machen dafür beschuldigt
niemand die polizei und wir müssen als
politiker dafür sorgen dass die polizei
auf wächst was ich übrigens in dieser
legislaturperiode beim bka bei der
bundespolizei auch übrigens für den zoll
mit organisiert habe und möglich gemacht
habe und für diese behörden über die wir
jetzt sprechen das heißt genau das was
notwendig ist es gemacht worden und das
ist meine leistungsbilanz auf die in
dieser frage auch sehr stolz partner
verlassen das geld müssen das jetzt
einmal so stehen lassen herr laschet es
verstehen lassen weil erstens ich bin
gemeinen die politik gegangen um redlich
zu argumentieren ich habe deutlich
gemacht dass sie eine aufsichtspflicht
haben und wenn sie jetzt sagen ja ich
habe so viel neue leute eingestellt und
bei bayer kann ich habe dies getan ich
habe das getan das ergebnis ihres tuns
ist dass die aufsicht versagt hat und
das millionen kleinanleger ihr geld
verloren hat und in dem sie sagen ja da
sitzt eine behörde in köln erwecken sie
den eindruck als wenn sie damit nichts
zu tun hätten darüber haben sie die
fachaufsicht über diese behörde und bei
comex das ist nun offenkundig haben sie
in hamburg versäumt rechtzeitig in der
frist das geld von denen die betrogen
haben ein so auch das ist der falsche
weg denn auch wir haben jetzt dreimal
die falschen behauptung wiederum sie
keine farbe und ich sage nochmal wir
haben eine aufsicht allerdings nicht
über die einzelentscheidungen nur das
will ich hier gar nicht anführen sondern
nochmal sie haben angefangen mit einer
falschen behauptung ihren ganzen vortrag
den sie eben gehalten haben über die
frage gegen wen eigentlich ermittelt
wird und das ist jetzt ja mal
klargestellt sie haben es nämlich nicht
wiederholt weil es falsch war und
deshalb habe ich noch mal darauf
hingewiesen dass wir eine sehr klare
strategie haben was alles zu tun ist das
habe ich auch gemacht und genau das
erwartet man von einem verantwortlichen
politiker dass er sich nicht wegduckt
sondern die dinge auf den weg bringt die
notwendig sind und wenn man eine so
kleine behörde übernimmt und sie groß
macht dann ist das richtig und wenn man
so große gesetzesänderung gegen
unglaublich viele lobbyisten durchsetzen
dann ist das auch richtig und wenn man
dafür sorgt dass comex und all diese
maßnahmen die gemacht haben worden sind
lange bevor ich bürgermeister oder
finanzminister war hart verfolgt werden
können dass nichts verkehrt dass wir
hinter allen hergehen und das ganze geld
wieder hören wollen dann ist das genau
das was man in dieser situation machen
muss und deshalb sage ich das ist geht
der richtige umgang mit dieser
herausforderung und das wird auch nicht
dadurch richtiger kritisiert dass man
mit falschen behauptungen gerüchten
durch die gegend wird also das wird
gerne alles wird gerne raus zwei punkte
ergänzen zum einen eine frage ganz
offene und ehrliche frage legen sie dann
den bericht das protokoll des
finanzausschusses des bundestags wird
das jetzt offengelegt noch vor der wahl
und der andere punkt der mir wichtig ist
weil wir nach vorne orientiert hier ja
in die bundestagswahl gehen das können
wir in zukunft besser machen wenn uns 50
milliarden jährlich als staat verloren
gehen durch geld wer schon mal muss sich
das mal überlegen das ist organisierte
kriminalität dass es drogenhandel das
ist mafia wird es von ihrer
bundesregierung beziehungsweise das ist
das was ich möchte wenn wir die
bundesregierung anführen als grüne nicht
mehr möglich sein dass wir mit bargeld
im großen großem maßstab
immobilienkäufer kaufen kann weil da
wird das ganze geld in deutschland
gewaschen und wir sind eins der länder
gerade im europäischen vergleich was mit
blick auf geldwäsche wirklich schlecht
dasteht und das will ich ändern ich will
dass wir in zukunft verbieten dass es
bargeld käufe in großem maßstab ist und
gegen diese der geldwäsche um gegen
diesen steuerbetrug vorzugehen haben sie
uns zu einem anderen thema kommen
laschet in südthüringen ist der frühere
verfassungsschutzchef maßen kandidat für
die cdu es ist heftig kritisiert worden
er sagt er will die fehler der regierung
merkel korrigieren er verbreitet auch
fake news über twitter wolfgang schäuble
hat nun gesagt dass dieser mann die
bandbreite der cdu abbildet hat herr
maßen für sie einen platz in der cdu
steht er in der mitte der partei er ist
mitglied der cdu und steht er in der
mitte der partei und gehörig datei steht
da nicht sondern ja er ist ein mitglied
der cdu und sie wissen dass wir ein
wahlrecht haben wo jeder einzelne
wahlkreis und demokratischen verfahren
seine kandidaten aufstellt dieser
wahlkreis hat sich für ein maß und
entschieden und wir respektieren wir
fahren ein mitglied ihres entschuldigung
das hat ein mitglied ihres sie nennt des
zukunftsteams karin prien mehr oder
weniger davon abgeraten herrn maßen zu
wählen und ihr auf den spd kandidaten im
fraglichen wahlkreis zu setzen würden
sie herrn maßen ihre stimme geben ich
wäre ja im wahlkreis aachen und vermaßen
hat gesagt frau catherine muss jetzt aus
dem zukunftsteam entfernt werden und
meine antwort ist karin prien bleibt da
drin die frage würden sie bestimmen wer
antwortet er auf keine würde fragen für
299 wahlkreise ich wähle im wahlkreis
aachen und es gibt viele unterschiede
das weiß aber jeder von mir und herrn
maßen und herr maßen wird sich an den
kurs halten müssen die ich vorgebe als
parteivorsitzender und wenn nicht das
vertrauen habe auch als bundeskanzler
das heißt wenn er sich über
massenzuwanderung äußert und
staatsbankrott äußert und sagt ich bin
noch nicht mitglied der cdu geworden
damit 1,8 millionen araber einwandern
können dann ist das etwas was sie
kritisieren und auch in haaren entgegnen
dass die entscheidung der
bundeskanzlerin
2015 richtig war dass sie die grenzen
nicht geschlossen hat dass wir für eine
geordnete migrationspolitik stehen
aber das alles was anderes von team aus
geäußert wird nicht akzeptabel ist wir
sind bei annalena baerbock es gibt einen
ich will jetzt nicht sagen
vergleichbaren fall aber es gibt auch in
ihrer partei die diskussion um ein
parteimitglied kann ganz unbekanntes
boris palmer nämlich gehört boris palmer
zu den grünen oder wenn nicht warum
nicht er ist mitglied unserer partei
arbeitet eine äußerung getätigt die
rassistisch war und deswegen habe ich
als parteivorsitzende und das
unterscheidet uns dann offensichtlich
auch an dieser stelle gesagt das kann
ich nicht so stehen lassen und mit ihm
gesprochen telefonierte und gesagt das
muss klargestellt werden es braucht eine
entschuldigung und da das nicht
stattgefunden hat haben dann die baden
württembergischen grünen auf einem
parteitag gesagt da müssen wir
überprüfen mit blick auf die
mitgliedschaft ob boris palmer wenn er
nicht bereit ist sich dafür zu
entschuldigen das klarzustellen mitglied
unserer partei bleiben kann und das ist
was ich glaube gerade in diesen zeiten
wo wir die nsu morde hatten wo wir hanau
das liegt jetzt zwei jahre zurück dieser
furchtbare anschlag auf eine synagoge wo
zwei menschen dann vor der tür ermordet
worden sind wo wir
alle natürlich wo wir hatten wo menschen
ermordet worden sind
jugendliche junge menschen wenn man den
eltern spricht die müssen daran glauben
dass in deutschland alles dafür getan
wird dass rassismus kein platz hat dass
menschen dass jugendliche in zweiter
dritter generation hier in deutschland
sicher sind und das erwarte ich auch von
einer volkspartei cdu da sie die
brandmauer nach rechts voll und ganz
schließt ich weiß wir wissen das glaube
ich alle als parteivorsitzender das ist
nicht immer einfach in den eigenen
parteien aber ihre vorgänger dann zum
beispiel annegret kramp karrenbauer hat
sich heftig auch mit einem landesverband
angelegt weil sie klar und deutlich
gemacht hat auch mit blick auf die af
die eben nicht eine gleichsetzung mit
links und afd sondern klar gesagt hat
wir müssen alles nach rechtsaußen
schließen und jedenfalls das ist für
mich ich bin ja parteivorsitzender
meiner partei ich trete ja für bündnis
90 die grünen an das oberste gebot auch
für die nächste bundesregierung
deutlich zu machen der kampf gegen
rassismus hat absolute priorität in
unserem land nochmals aber eine
erinnerung das war meine allererste
wortmeldung ihr heute abend dass die
grenze gegen rechts steht und dass die
größte bedrohung für die demokratie von
rechts ausgeht von menschen daniel morad
sei mit das bleibt nicht das haben wir
im deutschen bundestag getan werde eben
auch will sie genau zugehört hätten ich
habe das sehr sorgsam formuliert ich
habe gesagt die linke lehne ich ab aus
ein paar punkte die ich es nicht
wiederholen will weil es die sendung
verlängert aber die rechte bekämpfe ich
die gehören nicht in parlamente die sind
die die geistigen brandstifter die am
ende zu solchen morden führen wie auf
unseren partei vor meinen parteifreund
walter lübke und deshalb werden wir mit
denen nicht einmal reden nicht
kooperieren und eine klare brandmauer
haben und da hab ich nun auch persönlich
keinen nach unten dann kann sich die
linkspartei nicht mehr der afc ich hab
leider gleichgesetzt finde ich sage ich
teile nicht dass wir aus der nato
austreten dass wir gegen europa
untersagt mit beiden reden sie
kategorischen ist frau baerbock aber im
ergebnis rede ich denn ich habe gesagt
wie cool ihren nicht mit beiden wird
nicht kuriert das ist die autobahn ihren
sie ihre aufgaben ausgaben aus dem
bundestag dass er gut dann hat die
sendung ja sogar ein kleines korrigiert
aber lassen sich über das thema corona
einmal sprechen im augenblick stockt die
impfkampagne es wird immer wieder die
frage gestellt 2g 3g das ganze wird sich
aber alles nur verbessern wenn die
impfquote steigt was wollen sie tun um
mehr menschen dazu zu bewegen sich
impfen zu lassen
herzlich appell aber ich glaube das gilt
für uns alle drei hier weil wir alle
drei an der stelle genau das gleiche
erreichen wollen dass mehr menschen sich
impfen lassen daher bitte lassen sie
sich impfen kinder jugendliche haben in
den letzten anderthalb jahren alles
dafür getan dass erwachsene dass ältere
menschen sicher sind und jetzt müssen
wir als erwachsene alles dafür tun dass
kinder die noch nicht geimpft werden
können weiter in die schule weiter an
die kitas gehen können und was müssen
wir tun zum einen aber festhalten dass
nach anderthalb jahren pandemie jetzt
eine aktionswoche kommt das zeigt wie
mit ihrer regierung der großen koalition
sind wir immer nur auf sicht gefahren
und wir brauchen jetzt eine klare ansage
auch das finde ich kann man jetzt
abwarten wie nach der bundestagswahl
dann zu sagen wir müssen mal gucken ob 2
gilt sondern ich finde wir müssen jetzt
dafür sorgen dass die schulen dass die
kitas offen gehalten werden das bedeutet
auch für menschen die sich impfen lassen
wollen das ist ein freies land das sie
dann aber nicht die gleichen freiheiten
in intelligenz gebieten haben können wie
andere weil ansonsten werden wir in den
nächsten herbst reinrutschen wo die
krankenhäuser überfüllt sind und wie wir
drohen in den nächsten lockdown zu die
interessanterweise klare halde jetzt vor
der bundeswehr interessanterweise haben
sie alle drei einen weiteren lockdown
ausgeschlossen wir sind in einer
situation die selbst menschen die sich
gut auskennen man sagt expertin oder
wissenschaftler zu ihnen als vierte
welle betrachten und bezeichnen was
würden sie sagen herr laschet ist er
herr scholz entschuldigung ist jetzt die
beste art und weise ist das beste mittel
um die aus den 61 prozent impfquote die
wir jetzt haben
eine höhere zahl zu machen und mehr
menschen zu überzeugt wir müssen werben
dafür dass sich viele impfen lassen wir
müssen viele überzeugen und ich nutze
den wahlkampf jetzt wo ich auf vielen
marktplätzen spreche um ganz viele
anzusprechen überzeugt eure freunde eure
liebsten eure verwandten den sportverein
gegen bin stammtisch die kolleginnen und
kollegen im betrieb sagt ihnen das ist
doch gut was wir gemacht haben es
schützt euch und es schützt auch andere
und wir werden dass er die nächsten tage
noch mehr sehen die der anstieg der
infektionszahlen wird im wesentlichen
anstieg seien der etwas damit zu tun hat
dass die ungeimpften erwachsenen
gefährdet werden dass viele davon krank
werden sich anstecken dass einige auf
die intensivstation kommen und leider
auch einige sterben werden und deshalb
müssen wir alle davon überzeugen dass
sie sich jetzt impfen lassen und dann
möglichst vielen orten in deutschland
überall
dafür sorgen dass man eine möglichkeit
hat sich ganz allein
zu lassen zum beispiel ist das in
hamburg gemacht worden in der
elbphilharmonie oder sportstätten das
ist doch gut also dass der impfstoff zum
menschen kommt und nicht der mensch zum
impfstoff armin laschet was würden sie
sagen haben wir bisher nicht gemacht um
die menschen zu motivieren sich impfen
zu lassen es ist die rettung das ist war
deshalb starten wir es in der nächsten
woche eine große werbeaktion um jetzt
noch einmal die letzten kräfte zu
bündeln in nordrhein westfalen sind wir
in der oberen drittel im oberen drittel
beim impfen weil wir auch sehr früh
darauf geachtet haben mobil unterwegs zu
sein das haben wir schon gemacht als der
impfstoff noch knapp war auch im viertel
zu gehen wo die menschen nicht so den
zugang zu
information und b zum arzt haben dazu
impfen und das ist auch jetzt der fall
ein ganz ungewöhnliche orte olaf scholz
hat aus hamburg ein beispiel genannt ich
glaube das müssen wir jetzt tun wenn die
menschen nicht zum arzt gehen oder
vielleicht gar kein hausarzt haben
gerade junge menschen haben oft kein
hausarzt angebote machen da wo sie sind
in den universitäten in den klubs in den
innenstädten und so genau das ziel zu
schaffen so hoch zu kommen ohne eine
pflicht da sagen sie da dieses berühmte
wort von der impfpflicht würden sie ist
denn auch für bestimmte berufszweige
ausschließen muss nicht einen lehrer
muss nicht ein pfleger muss nicht mehr
ärzte schafften müssen nicht
krankenschwestern logischerweise geimpft
sein um eben anderen bürgern
gegenübertreten zu können die sie
betreuen
ich würde mir wünschen und das ist jetzt
in der letzten woche durch die
bundesregierung beschlossen worden dass
bestimmte berufsgruppen dem arbeitgeber
offen legen müssen ob sie geimpft sind
oder nicht ganz vertraulich aber man
muss in einem krankenhaus in einem
pflegeheim wissen sind die mitarbeiter
geimpft und die mitarbeiterinnen oder
nicht ich hätte etwas anderes als dass
wir das noch weitere berufe aus denen
das war nicht möglich aber um
gesundheitsschutz im betrieb zu halten
findet muss jeder das offenlegen wo sie
nächste frage auch annalena baerbock wie
würden sie entscheiden muss es eine
impfpflicht geben für bestimmte
berufe für bestimmte berufszweige die so
sehr nah am menschen sind dass sie eben
einfach selbst geschützt sein müssen um
andere nicht so effizient aus meiner
sicht kann es auch hier kein roman geben
weil das hat mir jetzt letzten
anderthalb jahre das immer so abgewartet
worden ist werden wir jetzt erleben dass
wir gerade mit blick auf
pflegeeinrichtung und krankenhäuser zu
der situation kommen dass nicht genug
beschäftigte geimpft sind dann sollte
aus meiner sicht diese diese frage
durchaus angegangen werden das gleiche
gilt sie wären für eine impfpflicht für
einzelne berufsgruppen wir haben das ja
zb bei der bundeswehr auch ist ja nicht
was was ganz komplett neu ist und wenn
wir jetzt die situation haben dass wir
zur auswahl haben schließen wieder kitas
und schulen gehen wir in den nächsten
lockdown dann muss aus meiner sicht
diese frage auch impfung für einzelne
berufsgruppen angegangen werden das ist
vor allen dingen auch der
bildungsbereich den wir da ganz klar ins
auge fassen müssen zwei tagen ist mir
extrem wichtig weil das ist so ein
bisschen man schiebt einige
entscheidungen weg und dann redet man
immer über die intensivste entscheidung
das ist nach wie vor von der
bundesregierung verweigert wird dass es
testung am arbeitsplatz gibt wir
verlangen dass von unseren kindern in
den schulen zwei bis dreimal die woche
zu testen aber am arbeitsplatz soll das
nicht passieren das verstehe ich einfach
nicht warum die einfachen schritte die
wir jetzt eigentlich gehen können und
gehen müssen dass die nicht getan werden
und das will ich in eine entscheidung
die jungen stolz zwei fragen also
entschuldigung sehr gleich richtig zu
beantworten impfpflicht für besondere
branchen und zweitens genau diese frage
warum gibt es darauf keine festlegung
also erstens bin ich gegen eine
impfpflicht aber ich bin dafür dass wir
alle überzeugen und dabei hilft das was
wir jetzt gesetz gewünscht auf den weg
gebracht haben nämlich dass in
bestimmten berufsbereichen gefragt
werden kann ob man sich impfen lassen
das fanden sich alle gut aber ich fand
das richtig ich habe mich sehr dafür
eingesetzt dass wir diese möglichkeit
jetzt schaffen und das wird dann auch
dazu führen dass wir einen besseren
überblick haben und dass man damit
umgehen kann ich glaube wir werden
feststellen dass sehr viele dort wo es
darauf ankommt auch von ihrer
möglichkeit gebrauch gemacht haben sich
impfen zu lassen und das zweite ist
natürlich testen wer an den schulen wir
testen auch mit den betrieben beide
rechtlichen grundlagen haben wir auf
basis der gesetze die jetzt unterwegs
sind auf den weg gebracht mit der
entscheidung dass wir die pandemische
lage noch mal ein paar monate vergangen
haben wir die grundlage für dieses
testen in betrieben und schulen gelegt
jetzt
die masken pflichten abgeschafft worden
ist im grunde alle beschränkungen
aufgehoben worden ist das nicht auch
möglicherweise etwas was das impfen
befördern kann so eine aussicht auf wenn
wir die und jene quote erreicht haben
dann sind alle beschränkungen weg würden
sie sagen es gibt eine zahl bei der wir
die masken pflicht beispielsweise
aufheben können finde dass deutschland
einen sehr klugen moderaten weg geht
bewerben für das impfen das tun wir auch
überein stimmt hier das finde ich sehr
gut weil es ja in länder gibt in denen
das in einer solchen runde keineswegs
der fall wäre das muss man ja auch mal
festhalten zweitens ist es so dass wir
dafür sorge tragen dass an orten wo das
sinn macht weiter masken getragen werden
zum beispiel in bahnen und bussen und
wir sorgen dafür dass getestet wird in
schulen und betrieben und wir wenden
vorsicht an regeln an wenn man in ein
restaurant geht in eine
kultureinrichtung in dem dort nicht alle
rein können so nur wer geimpft genesen
oder getestet ist und schaffen neue
möglichkeiten die auch vor ort ab und
drückt das sein wird das ist ja ein
wichtiges argument denn da finden
tatsächlich auch ansteckungen statt
warum wird das nicht weiter verfolgt war
die frage ich glaube dass es völlig
reicht dass die testmöglichkeit in den
betrieben existiert und dass es nicht
richtig wäre wenn wir jetzt die pflicht
der arbeitnehmern und arbeiten immer
konstruieren dass sie sich auch
entsprechend testen interessante
erhalten das sind dann eins der probleme
wir rauschen in den nächsten herbst
herein das heißt sie haben nichts daraus
gelernt von den anderthalb jahren
pandemie man sagt kindern von den
kindern das verlangen wir dinge die man
von erwachsenen nicht verlangt meine
kinder alle kinder in die land die in
die schule gehen müssen sich zwei mal
die woche manchmal sogar dreimal die
woche testen und warum sagen sie bei
kindern verlangen wir dass und bei
wachsen verlangt man das nicht ich finde
das eine absolute
ungleichbehandlung zwischen erwachsenen
und kindern wir müssten doch die
jüngsten wirklich schützen sie können ja
nicht sagen ja ich will die schulen
offen halten ja ich will keinen weiteren
lockdown aber die maßnahmen die wir
dafür brauchen gehen wenn ich an weil es
einfach entscheidungen gibt wo man sagt
wir wollen die bürgerinnen und bürger
überzeugen in diesem fall die
arbeitnehmern arbeitnehmer mein eindruck
von den betrieben ist dass das testen
breitflächig genutzt wird viele
beschäftigte haben davon gebrauch
gemacht und es hätte natürlich an könnte
es hätte natürlich konsequenzen wenn man
sagt man muss sich testen lassen würde
das ja bedeuten dass jemand
möglicherweise seinen arbeitsplatz
verlieren könnte wenn er das nicht
mitmacht und deshalb haben wir uns
anders entschieden und gesagt wir wollen
es mit der test angebots liegt für die
arbeitgeber organisieren und ich glaube
dass das in diesem stadium der pandemie
auch der richtige weg ist denn wir haben
ja schon sehr viele die geimpfte es
könnte konsequenzen haben für das
weitergehen dieser vierten welle wir
wollen an der stelle einmal ganz kurz
festhalten dass sie sich sehr fair
untereinander verteilt haben in bezug
auf die zeit ihres lebens und ihrer
äußerungen und würden dann genau an der
stelle weitermachen wir haben natürlich
genau bei corona und endlich das in der
fairness halber sagen darf die uhr von
herrn scholz läuft aber weiter
vielleicht angehalten werden ja im auge
zudem muss tatsächlich angehalten werden
aber wir achten darauf dass das alles
seine richtigkeit haben da
offensichtlich ein technisches problem
das stimmt es werden erklären und werden
sie sofort aufklären dazu das geht nicht
dass die weiterläuft doch wir haben
alles immer noch weiter noch blick und
kommen darauf unbedingt zurück weil das
geht auch anders der korona zeit gemerkt
dass vieles in deutschland auch nicht so
richtig funktioniert nicht nur diese uhr
sondern vieles andere auch nicht was die
digitalisierung angeht faxgeräte in
gesundheitsämtern und ähnliches warum
ist es in deutschland immer noch nicht
so dass es flächendeckend wirklich
schnelles internet gibt warum
herr laschet gibt es immer noch nicht 5g
an jeder milchkanne
als zu langsam gegangen ist weil zu
wenig investiert worden ist wir haben
viel aufgeholt aber es reicht nicht aus
was war ihre partei die regierung es
waren mehrere parteien in den letzten
jahren an der regierung meine auch wir
haben viel gemacht aber es reicht nicht
deshalb sage ich es keine hier kein
weiter so geben wir müssen auch da die
kräfte bündeln ich will ein
digitalisierungs ministerium errichten
das dann wirklich dieses thema mit all
den ganzen ebenen die im moment auf
viele häuser verteilt sind konzentriert
an geht es ärgert mich maßlos dass wir
immer noch selbst auf autobahnen
kernnetz haben das ist kein 4000 weiß
erlernt wie die bundesrepublik
deutschland die reden über 4000 weiße
flecke und über noch 4g und nun erinnern
wir uns ja auch das eigentlich über die
letzten vier legislaturen
digitalisierung immer angekündigt wurde
sie stand eigentlich in allen
wahlprogrammen und nicht nur einmal in
den wahlprogrammen sie kommt nur
irgendwie nie in der realität an was ist
ihr befund annalena baerbock warum ist
das so wo sind die größten makel beim
organisieren dieser neuen infrastruktur
und wann können wir endlich darauf
hoffen dass wir nicht mehr mit dem
faxgerät und nicht mehr zum perso
verlängern in das bürgeramt müssen
sondern diese dinge auch in einer
digitalen verwaltung ankommen warum ist
das so weil man in der letzten
bundesregierung und sie haben ja 16
jahre als union regiert diese frage
digitalisierung sowie die frage
klimaschutz muss zur absoluten chefin
sache gemacht hat digitalisierung ist
oder war muss man deutlich sagen die
aufgabe unserer zeit und sie haben dass
da so hin laufen lassen und zwischen den
ministerien einfache komplett verteilt
aber die frage was will ich anders
machen zukunftsthemen indes
bundeskanzlerin amt integrieren dass es
da eine zentrale koordinierung gibt da
braucht man kann ein ministerium für
sondern wir brauchen ja digitalisierung
in allen bereichen der justiz zum
beispiel da konkreter vorschlag von
meiner partei dass wir im bund länder
programm haben zur digitalisierung der
justiz wir erleben da dass wir viele
straftaten überhaupt nicht künftig
bundesländerübergreifend erfassen können
weil alles noch wie sie gesagt haben
frau illner per fax hin und her geht
beim glasfaserausbau hat ihr
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
versteigerungs runden gemacht das ist
immer immer teurer geworden
und da muss man jetzt die reißleine
ziehen so wie das zum beispiel spanien
gemacht hat und sagt das ist eine
hoheitliche staatliche aufgabe wir
müssen jetzt in den kommunen wo nicht
ausgebaut wird staatlich dort mit rein
gehen auch von der bundesebene um gerade
in ländlichen regionen wo ja selber in
ein bundesland wo wir viele viele weiße
flecken nach wie vor haben in
brandenburg das können wir uns nicht
leisten da sind dann nicht nur die
betriebe betroffen nicht nur die schulen
betroffen ärzte sagen ich kann doch hier
im ländlichen raum das was eigentlich
heute in der medizin möglich ist gerade
auch mit fern diagnostik gar nicht tätig
sein wenn ich keine vernünftigen
glasfaseranschluss habe und das heißt
das dann wirklich zur chefin sache zu
machen und zu sagen der ausbau hat
absolute priorität und da geht der staat
dann noch ein kind olaf scholz sagen wir
haben ja schon was getan wir haben zum
beispiel an den schulen einen digital
packt wir haben sechseinhalb milliarden
euro aufgelegt für die digitalisierung
von schulen allein das sagt gerade eine
steuer kfw studie das wird nicht
abgerufen und die studie sagt vor allen
dingen das liegt daran dass das
antragsverfahren so kompliziert und zu
wenig personal da ist daran kannst du
nun eigentlich wirklich nicht scheitern
daran kann es nicht scheitern soll es
auch nicht deshalb ein paar klare
aussagen ich glaube das liegt schon
längst nicht mehr am geld also für die
breitband infrastruktur für deutschland
haben wir zwölf milliarden euro
bereitgestellt an öffentlichem geld für
die förderung von
künstlicher intelligenz 5 milliarden für
die frage wie geht es weiter mit einem
quantencomputer 2 milliarden für die
frage wie kriegen wir noch die nächsten
schritte hin nach 5 g mit 6 g und opera
nochmal zwei milliarden also viel geld
und auch das geld das sie eben
angesprochen habe für den digital packt
der ist zu spät gekommen gut dass wir
uns in dieser legislaturperiode
vorgenommen haben das grundgesetz zu
ändern was wir mussten damit wir das
machen können das ist verhandelt worden
hat parteiübergreifend am ende auch
hingehauen und seitdem steht das geld
zur verfügung wenn wir früher los gelegt
hätten wären wir auch weiter gekommen
und aus meiner sicht ist das eine sache
die nicht aufhören darf denn wir müssen
sicherstellen dass mit der finanziellen
hilfe des bundes die länder und
gemeinden dafür sorgen dass alle schulen
an das netz angebunden sind und was mir
auch wichtig ist bei dieser frage ist
dass wir ein bisschen lernen wir aus der
rückschau denn was schiefgegangen ist zb
im bereich des mobilfunks war dass die
auflagen für die mobilfunknetzbetreiber
in der vergangenheit nicht hart genug
waren das haben wir diesmal anders
gemacht und darauf verzichtet dass wir
sehr sehr hohe erlöse erzielen können
wie das sonst der fall gewesen wäre und
bei früheren situationen auch der dann
eingetreten ist in dem wir gesagt haben
das wichtigste ist die verpflichtung der
netzbetreiber zu einem flächendeckenden
angebot in deutschland wir haben das
dann noch ergänzt mit zusätzlichen
fördermitteln die wir aus den einnahmen
generieren die wir dann erlöst haben und
das finde ich auch den richtigen weg und
bei der gigabit gesellschaft diese für
die infrastruktur in deutschland
brauchen da müssen wir auch dafür sorgen
dass es nicht nur dabei bleibt dass wir
fördermittel bereitstellen sondern wir
müssen auch sagen der eine infrastruktur
verantwortung hat muss auch dafür sorgen
dass das flächendeckend geschieht aber
wir haben ja ein administratives problem
weil wie sie eingangs sagten ja eben
offensichtlich das geld da ist aber dann
tatsächlich der techniker fehlt um die
schule anzubinden und die
systemadministratoren nicht da sind um
dafür zu sorgen dass auch arztpraxen
angeschlossen werden wir sind immer noch
bei der frage lehren aus corona
anderthalb jahren wir haben sie sahen
moderat durch diese zeit gefunden andere
sagen es waren eine menge nicht da es
war nicht rechtzeitig die masken da
nicht rechtzeitig der impfstoff da und
es gab eben tatsächlich auch das problem
die gesundheitsämter richtig anzubinden
ihre zentrale lehre aus diesen
anderthalb jahren die wir jetzt erlebt
haben wäre jeweils was muss dringend
anders gemacht werden und zwar ein etwas
heller schütten sie verändern was ist
ihre zentrale lehre aus diesem anlass
jahren kommen
ja vielen dank für die frage weil das
ist die hauptaufgabe für die nächste
bundesregierung liegen konsequenzen aus
dieser krise ziehen das eine ist
europäische autarkie und souveränität
dass wir wegen einem stück maske für
wenige cent irgendwo in der welt
produziert wochen lang einen
gesundheitsschutz hatte und die horrende
summen auf den weltmärkten bezahlt darf
nie wieder passieren wir müssen bei
medizinischen geräten bei masken
schutzkitteln auch sonstige geräte wo es
aber treffend nord sein war selbst diese
produkte herstellen
ihre wichtigste lehre
mit der politik schluss zu machen die
immer nur auf sicht fährt und nicht auf
vorsorge setzt und das heißt in so einer
partie in den ersten paar wochen wusste
niemand was diese pandemie bedeutet was
müssen wir eigentlich tun und dann war
aber vollkommen klar wir müssen
länderübergreifend zusammenarbeiten bund
und ländern europaweit zusammen arbeiten
und dann hätte es einen krisenstab
gebraucht und zwar im kanzlerin amt der
clark vor die mert was machen wir
eigentlich bei der beschaffung ganz am
anfang medizinisches personal was machen
wir bei den crooner hilfen das nicht der
finanzminister gegen den
wirtschaftsminister agiert und dann
kommen die korona hilfe nicht an was
machen wir mit blick auf die europäische
zusammen wäre note freuen krisenstab
damit es eine politische verantwortung
gibt es gebe ganz viel zu sagen aber ich
will weil das unmittelbar mit kroner
zusammenhängend sagen wir müssen den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst in
deutschland auf den modernsten stand
bringen da dürfen wir nicht mit aufhören
wenn die krise vorbei ist sondern das
ist eine aufgabe die die nächsten jahre
mit großem tempo voran gebracht werden
muss weil wir nicht wissen wann die
nächste große herausforderung auf
unseren gesundheitsdienst zukommt und
dann muss ja erstklassig digital
aufgestellt sein und ganz modern und mit
genug mitarbeitern mitarbeiter die dank
jetzt wurde uns gesagt dass die zeiten
die das stimmen wir werfen noch mal
einen kurzen blick darauf ganz furchtbar
weit sind alle nicht auseinander frau
bernburg hat einen kleinen vorsprung die
zeit von olaf scholz die eben weiter
lief ist auch korrigiert worden und wir
kommen herr laschet hat eben gesagt dass
die wichtigste aufgabe der neuen
bundesregierung möglicherweise ist aber
auch dass die größte aufgabe der neuen
bundesregierung nämlich die klimakrise
zu bewältigen frau berg die klima wende
wird mindestens so teuer wie die
deutsche einheit da sind sich eigentlich
alle einig warum schaffen wir den soli
für die deutsche einheit ab und machen
nicht einfach stattdessen ein klima soli
so dass jeder dafür zahlt einmal den
sprung hier vor der deutschen wende zum
klimaschutz machen also den soli
abzuschaffen das will ja herr laschet
ich will den soli nicht abschaffen aber
ich will ihnen vorliegen dafür nutzen um
kinder aus der armut zu holen bei
derzeit bezahlen ihn vor allem die
reichsten in unserem land mit blick auf
ihre frage zum klimaschutz ja das wird
ein riesen große kraftanstrengung für
unsere gesellschaft aber auch die größte
chance und deswegen müssen wir jetzt das
ist mein vorschlag mit blick auf das
geld 50 milliarden jährlich in unsere
infrastruktur
digitalisierung aber vor allen dingen
klima infrastruktur investieren das
heißt netze das heißt bahnausbau das
bedeutet windkraftanlagen zwei prozent
der landesfläche wirklich aufzustellen
auf jedes neue dach eine solaranlage
bringen weil wenn wir das nicht tun dann
wird's richtig richtig teuer dann wird
unbezahlbar und deswegen darf beim
klimaschutz jetzt keine halben sommer
soli oder nein und wir wandern zu hören
laschet und sagen weil jetzt ein solcher
tag ist endet man doch nicht die politik
das haben sie herr laschet in der
flutkatastrophe gesagt wie viele solcher
tage muss man haben damit sie ihre
politik ändern fakt ist seit 1900 den
neunziger jahren wissen wir von
weltklima ereignissen wir wissen seit
monaten von 3ds verfügt die auf der
straße sind dass etwas passieren muss
wir sehen
unwetterkatastrophen überall in der welt
wir sehen brennende und merken wie das
klima sich verändert und deshalb ist
nicht erst in dem moment wo wir selbst
auch mal erwischt sind
der zeitpunkt für eine politik änderung
da die die findet statt sie findet
übrigens in der falschen priorität statt
wenn das thema so wichtig ist wie ich es
halte er war die reihenfolge in
deutschland falsch zuerst aus der
kernenergie auszusteigen und dann aus
der kohle das ist jetzt geschichte aber
der weg war falsch denn wir sind jetzt
diese regierung hat den kohleausstieg
jetzt beschlossen im gegensatz zu dem
was vorher alles war wir sind beim umbau
unserer energie
wirtschaft und beim umbau unserer
industriegesellschaft und das ist die
eigentlich große leistung nicht mit
verboten und diesem und jenem sondern
tempo machen bei planung und genehmigung
die trassen schneller bauen und den
regenerativen strom vom norden in den
süden und industrie in die
industrieregionen zu bringen und
gleichzeitig unsere wirtschaft die
stahlindustrie die zementindustrie die
schäden so dass diese zu gestalten damit
sie klimaneutral wirtschaft
das ist keine frage von sprüchen sondern
wie man transformation in unserem land
leider sagen manche auch revolution zu
weil ist eine unglaubliche dimension ist
die der deutschen einheit eben in allein
ihren geldbeträgen nahe kommt mit
geschätzten einer billion um in diesem
bild noch mal zu bleiben herr laschet
also wenn da jetzt eine neue
kraftanstrengung wie die deutsche
einheit vor uns stünde dann wären
diesmal schon vorher die kassen leer es
würde alle deutschen betreffen und eine
figur wie helmut kohl wäre nicht da
ist das zu schaffen
ich glaube dass es viel bereitschaft
gibt ich bin ja mit der wirtschaft in
unserem land in intensiven gesprächen
die von sich aus angeboten haben wir
wollen den weg zur klimaneutralität
gehen die deutsche autoindustrie ist
längst auf diesem weg sich umzustellen
und ich finde wir müssen die jetzt auch
mal machen lassen die vorschriften die
die beiden wettbewerber alle vorhaben
werden das ziel nicht erreichen wir
haben so viel kreativität bei unseren
forschern wenn wir den durchbruch bei
der speichertechnologie zum beispiel
schaffen haben wir sehr viele fragen
gelöst
mit gesetzen mit verbotenen vorschriften
sondern in dem eine dynamik entsteht wo
auch jeder lust hat dass da etwas neues
entsteht und das ist eine bessere welt
wird wenn wir jetzt wissen sie mit der
gleichen dynamik den menschen in diesem
land vielleicht sagen dass es teuer
werden wird und das ist um all die dinge
des lebens des unmittelbaren lebens egal
ob wohnen verkehr oder auch arbeit eine
verteuerung geben wird die man
beschlossen hat eben wenn wir zu viel
co2 ausstoßen das haben sie auch in der
großen koalition noch beschlossen sie
haben auch beschlossen dass es sogar
noch schneller gehen soll weil karlsruhe
sie dazu verpflichtet hat wann fangen
sie an den menschen zu sagen dass sich
ihr leben verteuern wird wenn sie zu
viel co2 ausstoßen naja wir sagen vor
allem den menschen dass ihr leben besser
wird wenn sie klimaneutral leben und
wenn sie beispielsweise ein kfw programm
das wir was ich vorhabe einzuführen
nutzen dass die dachfläche zu einem
zinslosen darlehen mit photovoltaik
genutzt werden kann dann ist
lebensqualität mehr da aber es ist nicht
unbedingt so dass alles teurer das alles
trüber das alles mies
die menge teure so rangehen wirklich
gelingen wenn wir dann neue
arbeitsplätze schaffen neue modelle
entwickelt dann auch weltmarktführer
sind und die wieder exportieren können
geht es besser als mit dieser rhetorik
es wird alles schlecht es wird also das
recht aber es wird eine menge teurer
werden also zum beispiel sprit wird
teuerer daran aber die einnahmen die wir
aus der co2 steuer einnehmen wollen wir
nutzen um die bürokratische eeg-umlage
abzuschaffen das ist ein steuerungs
metern hat sich an der zapfsäule aber
möglicherweise wird sich das nicht so
schnell wieder spiegeln die der co2
preis auch herr scholz wird weiter
steigen wo ist ein benzinpreis an
spritpreis wo sie sagen da geht es nicht
weiter
ich bin davon überzeugt ist es richtig
ist bei der co2 preise moderat
vorzugehen so wie wir uns das
vorgenommen haben mit den gesetzen die
wir auf den weg gebracht haben haben
mich immer gegen all diejenigen gewährt
die gesagt haben das muss jetzt schnell
alles viel teurer werden weil es kauft
sich wegen eines steigenden spritpreise
es nicht am nächsten tag jemand ein
neues auto auch nicht weil das passiert
wegen der welt marktlage aber
auch nicht denn das aus steuerlichen
gründen passiert und deshalb ist richtig
dass wir sagen wir wollen einen
moderaten weg gehen und es ist auch
richtig dass wir sagen wir wollen in
dieser frage das geld den bürgern und
bürgern zurückgeben indem wir dafür
sorgen dass der strom billiger wird und
die kostenbelastung die auf der einen
moment das glatte gegenteil scholz der
strom ist teuer und wird immer teurer
das benzin wird teurer es gibt menschen
die können ihr wohnen nicht mehr
bezahlen und es wird in diesem land
verteilungskämpfe geben ich finde wenn
ich ihnen widersprechen darf das sind
die themen die man diskutieren muss und
deshalb sage ich moderater weg ist der
richtige weg aber das größte thema das
wir bewältigen muss ist ein großer
müssen ist ein großer industrieller
umbau und ich bin dagegen dass wir so
tun als ob das alles eine sache ist die
nur bei uns als einzelnen bürgern und
bürgern hängt wenn wir uns vornehmen 25
jahren und das hat deutschland per
gesetz beschlossen klimaneutral zu
wirtschaften dann ist das der größte
industrielle umbau die in deutschland
seit weit über 100 jahren vor sich hat
wir haben 250 jahre wirtschafts und
industriegeschichte hinter uns die auf
kohle gas und öl beruhen und wenn wir
das jetzt ändern dann bedeutet das dass
wir sehr viel auf den weg bringen müssen
damit das auch tatsächlich funktioniert
wenn sie an die projekt dann wollen sie
damit den leuten doch weiß machen das
macht die industrie damit habt ihr
nichts zu tun sie müssen doch irgendwann
anfangen den menschen zu sagen das wird
richtig kenne erstmal müssen wir damit
anfangen dass wir das industrieprojekt
auch richtig beschreiben denn die
deutsche wirtschaft will das ja was ich
hier gesagt habe die chemieindustrie
weiß was sie will die
stahlindustrie weiß was sie will die
zementindustrie weißt was sie will der
automobilbau weiß was er will der
maschinenbau alle sagen das geht aber
wir müssen dann statt kohle gas und öl
in ganz kurzer zeit strom einsetzen der
aus erneuerbaren quellen kommt also geht
es darum dass wir die
erzeugungskapazitäten in deutschland so
hoch machen plätze überhaupt sind die
chemische industrie zum beispiel sagt
sie braucht 2050 so viel strom wie
deutschland insgesamt und wenn wir für
diese aufgabe und zu drücken dann haben
wir ein problem deshalb meine klare
aussage zu diesem thema wir müssen
gleich am anfang der legislaturperiode
im ersten jahr weil wir ja nur diese
knapp 25 jahre haben dafür sorgen dass
genügend strom in deutschland erzeugt
wird damit all diese veränderung bei der
chemie bei der stahlindustrie bei all
den anderen wirtschaftszweigen unseres
landes stattfinden können dann wird uns
das auch gelingen dann wird unser leben
besser werden und das klima geschützt
werden können aber wenn wir das nicht
tun wenn wir nicht bereit sind auch
gesetze so zu ändern dass wir schnell
fertig sind dann wird das nicht klappen
weil es kann nicht sein dass eine
windkraftanlage zu genügen sechs jahre
dauert das muss auch in sechs monaten
gehen und das sind die dinge um die es
jetzt geht es geht wirklich um industrie
und wirtschaftspolitik
und ich möchte nicht dass wir die sache
so klein reden und sagen das hätte nur
etwas damit zu tun was jeder einzelne
von uns macht darauf kommt es auch an
und wollen sie haben gerade gesagt es
kann nicht sein dass das so lange dauert
wollen sie dann auch darauf setzen dass
anwohner eben dagegen nicht mehr klagen
dürfen das vielleicht fledermäuse nicht
mehr gerettet werden sondern brachial
einfach schneller werden es geht um zwei
prozent der landfläche und es geht um
offshore windenergie also windenergie
auf hoher see und es geht um
solarenergie was wir ausbauen müssen und
natürlich wird man klagen können aber es
wird nicht diese zeitverzögerung geben
können die wir heute haben wir müssen
also das bauplanungsrecht ändern wir
müssen auch dafür sorgen dass wir die
regelung zum umwelt- und artenschutz zu
ändern dass das schnelle genehmigung
geben kann es geht also um
geschwindigkeit dazu haben wir sehr
konkrete vorschläge schon sehr lange
gemacht und die wollen wir gerne
umsetzen und ich sage noch mal
wenn wir bei dem tempo bleiben das wir
heute haben dann werden wir kein
einziges dieser ziele erreichen und dann
wird das mit der klimaneutralität nicht
klappen
liebe ich meine das ist jetzt schön dass
sie vieles von dem übernehmen was die
union sagt also wenn ich mir diese
letzten vier jahre der großen koalition
anschaue war bei jenem bei jedem
beschleunigungs vorschlag bei jedem
entfesselung vorschlag die spd der
koalition und die grünen in der
opposition
die beiden parteien die das alles
blockiert hat das stück tausenden
argumente verlassen das stimmt sich
jetzt mal sehen vor zwei jahren traf
westfalen berichten wo wir entfesselung
spa käthe gemacht haben cdu und fdp
damit exakt die verfahren schneller
wären instanzen wegkommen wirklich mal
entschieden wird meinte sie an
assetklassen mal welcher in italien
verlassen oder sie reden mit einer
flasche sie reden drumherum sie können
sich keine
anderen anhören danach dürfen sie
entgegnen raten sie mal welche beiden
parteien sturm laufen gegen jede
einzelne vorschrift die wir wegnehmen
wenn das jetzt alles anders ist und wenn
sie nicht so für sich sprechen sondern
auch für die vielen abgeordneten partei
die das gegenteil verkünden dann ist das
ein gutes signal ich glaub es nur nicht
weil ich vier jahre bei ihnen anders
erlebt hat man muss ja an dieser stelle
sagen dass sie ein bisschen sich davor
drücken die wahrheit zuzugeben die
wahrheit ist dass sie vor zwei jahren
als cdu csu gesagt haben man braucht
nicht mehr strom wie weit ist dass sie
vor einem jahr gesagt haben man braucht
nicht mehr strom die wahrheit ist dass
sie noch im juni gesagt haben man
braucht nicht mehr strom und das heißt
man muss zusammenpassen aus dieser linie
feucht eine weitere von der cdu csu
geführte bundesregierung würde
deutschland wohlstand und arbeitsplätze
kosten weil es nicht gelingen könnte
stahlindustrie chemie industrie
maschinenbau zement wirtschaft so zu
modernisieren wie das notwendig ist weil
sie sich dagegen gewehrt haben bis
zuletzt und das ist glaube ich der
vorwurf dem sie akzeptieren müssen und
deshalb bin ich dafür dass wir die
ausbauziele hoch setzen und dass wir
alle gesetze so ändern dass wir in ganz
kurzer zeit fertig werden dazu haben wir
sehr konkrete vorschläge auf den tisch
wie übrigens auch ihr
einige gameplay gebildet werden wenn das
heute bei ihnen alles anders ist das in
ordnung in vier jahren war das nicht
möglich ich habe auch die
koalitionsverhandlungen damals
mitgemacht beim energiethema ihre partei
war immer die nicht mehr wollte aber
wenn alle jetzt wären planen muss
schneller werden gut aber eines ist
nicht wahr es war keine parteipolitische
frage wie viel strom gebraucht wird
sondern es gab eine analyse des
bundeswirtschaftsministeriums
mit zwei instituten renommierten
instituten dem öko institut in freiburg
und prognos die eine bestimmte menge
benannt haben und dann hat man die neuen
ausbauphase betrachtet und jetzt hat der
wirtschaftsminister
die neuen zahlen vorgelegt insofern wenn
sie der wissenschaft vertrauen müssen
sie auch gutachten die wissenschaftler
machen akzeptieren die politik hat die
schlüsse daraus zu ziehen und dann hat
sie auch die konsequenzen haben den
ausbau zu machen
laschet hat gegeben dass er stimmt dass
er vor zwei jahren vor einem jahr noch
verdeckt vor drei monaten gesagt hat man
braucht nicht mehr strom und dass er
sich geirrt hat als bonus das finde ich
sah dass winter ist der entscheidende
punkt der bundes nicht mit der
bundesregierung aber sie sind derjenige
der zusammen mit all ihren
parteifreunden die wichtigste
modernisierungs aufgabe deutschlands
verpasst hat im licht weil sie nicht
wollten dass wir den stahlunternehmen
den chemie in unternehmen der
zementindustrie den strom geben den sie
für eine wirtschaft brauchen die ohne
kohle gas und es ist unsere aufgabe des
bundesfinanzministers
unwürdig zu sagen sie haben mit der
stahlindustrie nicht gemacht ich habe
wahrscheinlich in den letzten jahren
mehr mit der stahlindustrie mit
thyssenkrupp und anderen gesprochen wie
wir das hinkriegen als sie das cover
wenn sie jetzt das einfach herzustellen
und zu sagen ihr könnt auch fair
miteinander umgehen aber sie können noch
nicht sagen wenn ich als
ministerpräsident alles tue eine
transformation der industriegesellschaft
einzuleiten vor wenigen wochen noch mit
den großen unternehmen dax konzerne des
landes zusammen gesessen hat die viele
ideen entwickelt haben die wir jetzt
aufgreifen müssen und die meistens auch
an den bedenken ihrer partei gescheitert
sind da kommen sie doch nicht hier so
raus ich meine langsam sie haben das
alles vergessen oder können sich nicht
erinnern ich sag's ihnen jetzt damit sie
es wissen wir arbeiten an diesem thema
und scheitern an den bürokraten in ihrer
partie wurde jetzt
das wort geben das soll es auch im
wirklichen leben behalten wenn ich das
kurz sagen darf dass sich an laschet
nicht zustimme und dass er diese fragen
klage den lesern von sobald
er bock ist dran und hilft uns
vielleicht noch einmal bei der
beantwortung von zwei sehr klaren und
einfachen fragen erstens müssen wir für
das von der großen koalition
beschlossene klimaschutzgesetz früher
aus der kohle aussteigen als
2038 und die zweite frage ist 75 euro
wollen sie den bürgern zurückgeben in
einem sogenannten bürgergeld das ist ne
tank quittung wird das reichen mann ist
er drei facette vielleicht mal der erste
punkt angefangen sie haben jetzt hier
beide in ihrer vergangenheitsbewältigung
der cdu und der spd deutlich gemacht
warum wir beim klimaschutz da stehen wo
wir derzeit stehen und das bedeutet wir
verfehlen unsere klimaziele mit
dramatischen auswirkungen weil sie beide
deutlich gemacht haben sie haben sich
nicht an den lösungen orientieren
sondern sie haben sich immer nur die
schuld in die schuhe geschoben wer
eigentlich was verhindert und wenn wir
jetzt über die zukunft reden und das
will ich es geht ja um die nächste wahl
und diese nächste bundesregierung die
ist die die noch aktiv einfluss auf die
klimakrise erlegen kann und das heißt
dann wir müssen früher aus der kohle
aussteigen und zwar deutlich vor
2038 wir können doch nicht das wollen
sie beide aber wenn sie jetzt ihre
meinung ändern weil sie sagen wir sind
jetzt die größten klima schütze dann
wäre es ja super dann hätten wir schon
mal ein erfolg wir können auch nicht 17
jahre lang weiter so machen als wäre
nichts passiert deswegen ist für mich
klar die nächste bundesregierung muss
den kohleausstieg vorziehen auf 2.030
wir müssen zweitens im automobilbereich
in der mobilität
ich überhaupt auf die klimaziele kommen
sie haben gefragt was ist das mit dem
gesetz der bundesregierung nachdem das
bundesverfassungsgericht ja gesagt hat
liebe große koalition so geht das nicht
weiter ihr gefährdet die freiheit unser
kinder haben sie gesagt okay wir haben
verstanden aber was war die einzige
maßnahme die sie gemacht haben sie haben
für in 25 jahren beschlossen dann
sollten wir beim klimaschutz weiter
seien aber für hier und heute keine
antwort gegeben und die zweite antwort
muss deswegen sein wir müssen raus aus
dem fossilen verbrennungsmotor und sie
kommen wir damit ihren schlagworten
immer von verboten jedes verbot ist auch
ein innovationstreiber das sehen wir
doch jetzt bei den deutschen
automobilherstellern die zuschauer
unruhig und wo ich wo ich nicht erst im
wahlkampf so wünschen ohne verbot
vorbeigeschaut habe sondern in den
letzten acht jahren in dem ich
wirtschafts und klimapolitik mache ist
ganz klar gewesen die zukunft im
individualverkehr ist elektromotor und
deswegen braucht es vor 2030 muss dafür
gesorgt werden dass dann nur noch
emissionsfreie fahren und 70 euro der
dritte punkt ist die industrie und da
brauchen wir keine analyse herr scholz
die industrie sagt wir brauchen jetzt
die wasserstoff infrastruktur
deswegen will ich dass wir energie
partnerschaft mit anderen ländern
schaffen und die infrastruktur verlegen
und dafür brauchen wir das geld dass sie
nicht bereit stellen jetzt auf die frage
75 euro das sind alles die politischen
aufgaben und wir können uns in groß und
die sind groß und die brauchen wir mit
klaren gesetzlichen regelung weil wenn
sie die nicht wollen dann müssen wir das
alles über den co2 preis machen das
möchte ich nicht das wäre nämlich sozial
ungerecht sondern unser vorschlag ist
dass wir signalisieren fossile energie
wird teurer beim tanken bei der heizung
aber damit dass sozial gerechtes geben
wir jährlich 75 euro pro person an die
menschen zurück aber nur als ein
bestandteil die andere frage die sie
angesprochen haben ist die unterstützung
bei menschen die das auto wechseln indem
wir die umstiegs prämie bei elektroautos
erhöhen von 6000 euro auf 9000 euro für
menschen die ein geringes einkommen
haben und der dritte punkt und da ist
blockieren sie auch derzeit ist dass er
mit blick auf die heizungen sagen das
könnte ich die mieterin bezahlen
zukünftig wird wir halten ganz kurz fest
dass sie sich schon wieder total fair
untereinander behandeln man möchte es
nicht glauben wenigstens auf die zeit
bezogen ist das so einen kleinen
vorsprung hat frau berbalk und auch nur
wegen dieses letzten statements wir
wandern jetzt tatsächlich zum wohnen und
zum heizen und möchten als allererstes
fragen frau baerbock wohnungsnot in den
städten ist ein massives problem das
weiß jeder und hat es natürlich auch
verfolgt jetzt jüngst am wochenende hier
wenigstens in berlin die grüne
spitzenkandidatin will für enteignung
von wohnungsbaugesellschaften stimmen
würden sie das auch ganz kurze antwort
nein und das soll auch nicht die grüne
spitzenkandidatin sondern sie hat einen
fairen pakt vorgeschlagen
sie hat deutlich gemacht damit wir
enteignung verhindern weil wir das nicht
wollen müssen wir jetzt mit einer klaren
regelung zum mietpreis oder bringen die
grenze in den städten wie berlin wo
menschen aus ihren vierteln vertrieben
werden dafür sorgen dass es zu dieser
maßnahme nicht kommen wird und das ist
auch mein vorschlag dass auf bundesebene
den städten ermöglicht wird so wirklich
die mieten explodieren dass man dort mit
preisobergrenzen einziehen kann ich
würde nur die antworten der beiden
von den beinen
das ist ja spannend wollen sie aus der
kohle früher aussteigen ja oder nein
schon beim
einheiten sie haben es gerade
angesprochen eine mietobergrenze mieten
deckel wie auch immer man das will ist
in berlin gerade sozusagen
verfassungsrechtlich gescheitert aber
man kann es bundesweit einführen wenn
man das möchte herr laschet herr scholz
was war die frage ob einmieten deckel
eine mietobergrenze ein weg ist die
mieten zu begrenzen und mieter zu
entlarven dieser mieten deckel den rot
rot grün in berlin erdacht hat ist ja
gerade vor dem verfassungsgericht
gescheitert in berlin wird immer weniger
investiert und deshalb ist doch das
entscheidende
wir brauchen mehr wohnraum wir brauchen
mehr bauen wir brauchen mehr und
schnelleres bauen das muss doch das ziel
sein das hat aber nur sehr langfristig
die mieten sozusagen etwas entlassen
wenn sie jetzt kurzfristig mietern
helfen wollen dass die mieten nicht mehr
steigen was schlagen sie dabei wir haben
ja mehrere mechanismen mieten können ja
auch nicht ins uferlose steigen wir
haben ja heute schon regeln wie mieten
steigen können aber die frage ist doch
ob sie jemanden den sie ermutigen wollen
dass er baut dass er endlich mehr
wohnungen baut damit ermutigen dass sie
ihm gleichzeitig so viele schranken
auflegen dass sie das geld woanders
investiert wir müssen doch dem der geld
investieren will sagen 'bitte nicht da
und da und da und da sondern ein anreiz
tue es beim wohnen mach es beim bauen
hier ist das bauland hier ist die
entbürokratisierung hier ist die
einfachere bauordnung fun & bauer so
aber nun all das was da erdacht wird
macht es komplizierter und ich sag es
wird nichts helfen bei der not in den
großen städten die wir derzeit haben
geller herr scholz macht es das wissens
schneller wer einen mieten deckel eine
stärkere mietpreis bremse ich glaube
dass wir zwei dinge gleichzeitig
anpacken müssen dass eines mehr
wohnungen bauen wir haben es in
deutschland schon mal geschafft 800.000
wohnung in einem jahr zu bauen das war
1973 da werden wir es wohl jetzt
schaffen jedes jahr 400.000 wohnungen zu
bauen das sind 100.000 mehr als jetzt
und darunter müssen auch 100000
geförderte sozialwohnung sein sonst
werden wir das nicht hinbekommen dass
wir in irgendeiner weise das wohnungsnot
problem in den städten den orten wo
viele hinziehen wollen lösen können so
und daneben brauchen wir aber weil das
ja eine gewisse zeit dauert auch alles
was dazu beiträgt dass die mieten jetzt
nicht durch die decke schießen und
deshalb bin ich dafür dass wir bei
neuvermietung den anstieg der mitte
begrenzen die gesetze haben wir die
müssen wird das besser machen uns
verlängern und das wir aber auch dafür
sorgen dass die mieten nicht in den
nächsten jahren so sehr steigen können
wie sie ohne eine zusätzliche mit ihnen
als bundeskanzler würde es einen mieten
deckel geben den sie bundesweit
anstreben streben ein mit moratorium ein
das bedeutet dass die mit anstiege
begrenzt sind in etwa in richtung der
inflationsrate nicht so sehr steigen
können wie sie es gegenwärtig tun aber
wir wollen keinen beschluss machen der
lautet gar keine steigerung mehr pro tag
herr laschet sie haben proben geredet
und dem gedanken folgt man natürlich
irgendwie erstmal sofort pro tag werden
in deutschland
72 wohnungen aus der sozialbindung
genommen das sind im jahr hochgerechnet
um die 30.000 diesen prozess und vorgang
beklagen wir schon eine ganze weile wenn
sie wiederum mit der dynamik noch mal
beschreiben wie man eben bezahlbaren
wohnraum also bezahlbare sozialwohnungen
baut und möglichst schnell wären ihnen
die bürger sicher auch dann ja aber das
gehört dazu wir brauchen mehr wohnungen
aber wir brauchen auch mehr sozialen
wohnungsbau wir haben die programme und
der muss ausgedehnt werden weil exakt
das phänomen stimmt viele zeiten laufen
aus dafür brauchen wir neue bezahlbare
sozialwohnungen sind haben wir 70 b 7 in
meinem land und sie müssen in ganz
deutschland so gebaut werden damit wir
diese ausgewogenheit und den sozialen
zusammenhalt übrigens auch in den
vierteln hinkriegen und ein zweites ist
glaube ich auch noch wichtig wir müssen
das wohnen im ländlichen raum attraktiv
halten damit nicht jeder glaubt für
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse muss er
in die stadt ziehen das überhitzt ja
noch einmal mehr die wohnungsmärkte in
den städten und deshalb will ich mich
dafür einsetzen dass wir auch im
ländlichen raum möglichkeiten haben doch
zu leben da geht vom schnellen internet
bis hin zu einer unterversorgung und die
haben sie haben das thema wohnen
ganzheitlich denken um erfolgreich zu
haben das thema sozialen zusammenhalt
angesprochen herr scholz dirigieren seit
1998 mit einer unterbrechung immer
mitunter immer hieß es weg mit der
zweiklassengesellschaft im
gesundheitssystem wie ist es dazu
gekommen sichern sie jetzt zu ein
nächster koalitionsvertrag wird eine
bürgerversicherung also eine
krankenversicherung in die alle
einzahlen
definitiv enthalten wir würden das gerne
voranbringen das hat auch in den letzten
wahl programm gestanden aber wir haben
uns nicht verständigen können das kann
man ja mal so sagen ich glaube dass ganz
besonders im bereich der pflege deutlich
wird wie sodass hin macht dort die
gleichen leistungen erbracht es werden
zwei kassen gesammelt wenn man das
besser zusammenführen würde dann hätten
alle mehr geld das wir billiger und wir
könnten dafür sorge tragen dass die
löhne und gehälter für die pflegekräfte
steigende könnten dafür sorge tragen
dass die angebote besser werden wir
könnten dafür sorgen dass mehr
arbeitskräfte in der pflege tätig sind
denn viele können sich ja
kaum noch vorstellen dass sie lange dort
bleiben der wechsel ist ungefähr sieben
bis neun jahre bleibt jemand da in den
beruf und dann wechselt er das ist nicht
gut und wenn wir das ändern wollen
müssen wir mehr solidarität schaffe und
dazu würde diese zusammenarbeit diese
kooperation aber machen sie das zur
bedingung also ich möchte nur verstehen
ob das eine herzensangelegenheit ist
oder verhandlungsmasse das ist eine
herzensangelegenheit schon seit langer
zeit und deshalb möchte ich gerne also
starkes mandat dass sich das auch
durchsetzen kürzere bedingungen machen
ich finde alles was in meinem
wahlprogramm steht es eine bedingung und
dann gucken wir mal wie weit bekommen
kurze frage an alle sollen private
krankenkassen abgeschafft werden nein
hier unterscheiden wir uns fundamental
fundamental und mich wundert auch dass
man angesichts der erfahrungen in europa
als finanzminister einen solchen
vorschlag machen kann die
einheitsversicherung die wir haben in
europa
dänemark in großbritannien haben ein
schlechteres gesundheitssystems erfolge
und die die es sich leisten können
finden wieder ihre umwege wie sie beste
gesundheit für sich selbst dann
organisieren und deshalb ist unser
gesundheitssystem gut es ist ein starkes
gesundheitssystem und dies in frage zu
stellen mit solchen einheits modellen
halte ich das ist die idee von armin
laschet wir wollen unbedingt noch hören
wie das gesundheitswesen der zukunft von
annalena baerbock aussieht wir können
jetzt nicht corona pandemie haben wo
menschen alles in den krankenhäusern
gegeben haben und dann sagen wir können
nicht mehr es reicht nicht wenn ihr uns
als pflegekräfte als erste beklatscht
sondern es muss sich etwas ändern und
das hat für mich absolute priorität in
der neuen bundesregierung dafür zu
sorgen dass unsere gesetzliche
krankenversicherung unsere öffentlichen
krankenhäuser gestärkt werden dh beim
fallpauschalensystem klingt total
technik aber das bedeutet dass wir nicht
alles nur auf profit was rechnet sich
auslegen sondern vorsorge element aus
öffentlicher hand einziehen damit die
betten auch wirklich zur verfügung
stehen damit menschen sich nicht kaputt
arbeiten und ja ich will dem weg zu
einer bürgerversicherung gehen die
bedeutet dass viel mehr menschen
einzahlen die erste schritt ist dafür zu
sorgen dass menschen die jetzt privat
versichert sind in die gesetzliche
wechseln können das wollen ja ganz viele
menschen weil dieses zwei klassen system
führt auch dazu dass zum beispiel in
ländlichen regionen wo fachärzte
mangelware sind wenn man anruft und sagt
ich bräuchte einen termin beim hautarzt
immer gefragt wird sind sie gesetzlich
oder privat versichert und wenn du
privat versichert ist kann sogar schnell
kommen und gesetzlich musste monatelang
warten und das halte ich für zutiefst
ungerecht das ist also ein thema wo sie
beide sich einigen können frau werbung
und herr scholz das sieht bei der rente
sehr ähnlich aus sie wollen beide ein
rentenniveau von 48 prozent
garantieren im augenblick ist das schon
und kostet sehr sehr viel geld wenn das
für die zukunft weiter garantiert werden
soll dann wird es noch viel mehr
steuergeld steuerzuschuss kosten das ist
doch aber eigentlich unbezahlbar es ist
nicht unbezahlbar das ist aus meiner
sicht eine mehr und deshalb will ich das
auch gern begründen wenn sie das mir
gestatten erstens wir haben in den 90er
jahren viele experten experten gehört
die haben uns erzählt das wird alles
nichts werden mit der rente das klappt
alles nicht mehr sie haben uns für diese
zeit vorher gesagt dass wir sehr hohe
beiträge zahlen werden sie haben uns
auch gesagt dass wir viel weniger
arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmer haben
werden das gegenteil ist eingetreten
bezahlen heute geringere beiträge als
zurzeit von helmut kohl und wir sind
jetzt in einer situation wo wir etwa
sechs millionen arbeitnehmern und
arbeiten immer mehr haben die in die
rentenkasse einzahlen und deshalb ist
die antwort für die zukunft auch dass
wir sicherstellen müssen dass möglichst
viele eine gute beschäftigung haben wenn
wir vorankommen würden zum beispiel bei
der beschäftigung
möglich bei den
beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten und chancen
von frauen dann wäre das ein ganz ganz
großer fortschritt und würde für die
frauen gut sein und für die rente wenn
jemand der mit 56 seinen job verliert
eine plausible annahme haben kann dass
er auch wieder einen guten neuen job
findet dann würde das auch schon viel dh
sie sagen dass diese 48% wir erinnern
uns an die doppelte haltelinie von
andrea nahles dass die auch für einen
berufseinsteiger für einen studierenden
heute ein versprechen in die zukunft ist
das ist mir sogar sehr wichtig dass man
über rente gesprochen wird immer gedacht
das geht nur um die renten und rentner
um die geht die 50 jährigen sondern es
geht auch um die jungen leute wer jetzt
mit 17 die schule verlässt der junge
mann die junge frau einen lauf gehabt
nach neuen zahlen fünf jahrzehnte
beiträge und die müssen natürlich wissen
ob sich das am ende auch austrägt und
deshalb eine ganz klare aussage wir
müssen ihnen die garantie geben dass es
erstens keinen weiteren anstieg des
renteneintrittsalters gibt und zweitens
dass wir dafür sorge tragen dass das
rentenniveau auch stabil bleibt war
diese zeit aber bis 2025 haben wir das
ja auch jetzt schon in der finanzplanung
sei es geht auch länger
das ist
nämlich genau die sie können sich gleich
zur olaf scholz äußern wir würden
trotzdem gerne wissen mit ihnen als
bundeskanzler
lebensarbeitszeit bis 67 48 prozent wird
gehalten fragezeichen also ja ich kann
das verbinden mit der antwort dass die
antwort nicht seriöses sie können nicht
einem der heute in das berufsleben
einsteigt sagen es wird alles so bleiben
wie es ist dieses weiter so wird uns da
nicht helfen sondern wir werden über
neue formen nachdenken müssen dafür gibt
es renten kommissionen und wir werden
am liebsten aus meiner sicht
parteiübergreifend auch mit dem der dann
opposition ist ein neues rentensystem
entwerfen können aber wenn man sagt dass
bleibt gleich das bleibt gleich jedes
jahr tun wir neue milliarden aus dem
bundeszuschuss drauf dann geht das exakt
zu dieser zulasten dieser jungen
generation die sie gerade angesprochen
haben denn die werden das zahlen müssen
den heutigen rentnerinnen und rentnern
können wir doch alle sagen eure rente
ist sicher und es war übrigens norbert
blüm der damals dieses system verteidigt
hat der gesetzlichen rentenversicherung
gegen all die die außerhalb als experten
rat gegeben haben und gesagt haben dass
brauchen wenn ich es ist gut dass wir es
haben aber es muss weiter entwickelt
werden und deshalb
ist eine stellschraube unsere generation
rente wie wir bei jedem neu geborenen
ansetzen wollen wo wir einen fond
aufbauen wo auch dessen rente in der
zukunft einmal gesichert ist wir müssen
bei der betrieblichen altersversorgung
ein besseres system an die riester-rente
die mal eingeführt wurde ist so nicht
effektiv und nicht tragbar wir brauchen
ein paar stellt schauen aber nur ein
weiter so wir müssen nichts ändern
verspricht den menschen keine seriöse
erwarten bessere idee als immer mehr
geld jetzt sind schon 26 prozent des
bundeshaushalts fließen in die
rentenkasse ist das nicht sind die
vorschläge von herrn lasseter nicht ein
bisschen zielführender na ja herr
laschet macht den ganzen abend sagte
immer analyse und was irgendwie in 20
jahren passieren soll beim klima in 20
jahren und bei der rente sagen sie auch
dann jetzt zahlen sie ein für in 40
jahren wenn jugendliche in rente gehen
aber wir müssen doch jetzt dafür sorgen
dass wir das rentenniveau stabilisieren
dass wir die beitragssätze stabilisieren
und vor allen dingen rentnerinnen und
rentner die nach wie vor am ende des
monats jeden euro umdrehen müssen nicht
wissen kann ich mir das
geburtstagsgeschenk für meine enkelin
noch leichten da müssen wir doch für
eine echte garantie rente sorgen und
deswegen ist mein vorschlag durch vier
konkrete punkte zum teil überschneiden
die sich in dem wir jetzt dafür sorgen
dass das rückgrat dieses sozialstaats
eine gesetzliche rentenversicherung
gestärkt wird und dass erste elf und das
wollen sie nicht und deswegen haben wir
ein problem fachkräfte zuwanderung wir
sind ein einwanderungsland wenn wir die
menschen die hier leben allen
ermöglichen auch zu arbeiten dann zahlen
sie in die sozialversicherungssysteme
wirklich mit ein der zweite punkt ist
wir brauchen einen gesetzlichen
mindestlohn von 12 euro und weil das für
aber dann die renten am ende noch nicht
ausreicht eine anhebung des
arbeitgeberanteils bei der einzahlung in
die rente auf 15 euro auch das
stabilisiert die rentenkassen der dritte
punkt ist wir müssen endlich dafür
sorgen dass all die millionen frauen die
eigentlich in vollzeit arbeiten wollen
das aber nicht können weil wir nicht
genug kinderbetreuungsplätze haben
endlich in vollzeit arbeiten auch die
zahlen in die rente dann entsprechend 1
und der vierte punkt der klingt klein
aber der gehört zur solidarität dazu
selbstständige auch die sollten in die
gesetzliche rentenversicherung mit 1
sein können und zuallererst abgeordnete
minister leute wie wir damit für die
gesetzliche rente noch mal auf die
zahlen das haben wir nicht nur
versprochen sondern das tun wir auch sie
sind erstens immer noch korrekt das ist
schön und zweitens liegen sie wirklich
mit minimalen unterschieden strecken
weil sie nur um sekunden auseinander es
ist ein gebot der fairness dass immer
wieder zu sagen dass sie diese dinge
untereinander wie gesagt die zeit
betreffend wenigstens gut
austarieren wir wollen und müssen uns
natürlich noch mal mit dem großen thema
steuern und finanzen befassen vielleicht
ist aber der hinweis ganz gut die frage
einzuschließen damit wir sie nicht
vergessen nämlich die nach der
zuwanderung wir haben eine zahl in der
großen koalition auf die hat man sich
verständigt von 150 bis 200 tausend
menschen die als asylsuchende nach
deutschland kommen und es gibt herr
laschet 400.000 das an notierte
bundesanstalt für arbeit die wir
bräuchten um unsere wirtschaft am laufen
zu halten
was sagt armin laschet wenn er
zukünftige bundeskanzler wäre zu diesen
beiden zahlen ungefähr auch 150000
asylsuchende bis 200.000 und ungefähr
400.000 menschen pro jahr die wir
brauchen am arbeitsmarkt
fakt ist dass wir heute ein modernes
einwanderungsgesetz haben insofern habe
ich gar nicht verstanden weshalb sie
gesagt haben wir seien dagegen wir haben
es und wir müssen um qualifizierte
zuwanderung in der welt werben dazu
brauchen wir ein neues klima das
signalisiert wir laden jeden ein der
einen beitrag leisten kann nach
deutschland zu kommen wir sind gegen
eine einwanderung in die sozialsysteme
sondern es geht darum qualifizierte
einwanderung nach deutschland
besser möglich zu machen als das heute
der frage noch mal nach der zweite teil
ihren zahlen das asylrecht kennt keine
obergrenze wir können zielgrößen
definieren das sind die 150 bis 200
tausend aber wenn jemand einen
rechtsanspruch hat und er politisch
verfolgt ist kann er auch dieses recht
in anspruch nehmen und deshalb wollen
wir eine sehr geordnete migration keine
illegale migration kein schlepper tun
sondern eine geordnete migration vor
allem migration in den arbeitsmarkt da
wo menschen gebraucht werden und ich bin
auch dafür dass potenzial derer zu
nutzen die im land sind die deutsche
sprache haben die zum teil in
ausbildungen sind noch besser zu nutzen
in nordrhein westfalen haben wir sehr
weite bleibe möglichkeiten für die die
gut integriert sind weil in jedem steckt
ein potenzial und das müssen wir haben
gut haben sie uns zum thema steuern und
finanzen kommen herr laschet kriegen wir
von ihnen heute abend das versprechen
dass in einer regierung laschet keine
steuern erhöht werden für niemanden
steuererhöhungen sind in dieser phase
unserer wirtschaft der falsche weg weil
wir haben mit viel geld die betriebe
durch die pandemie gebracht jetzt ist
die zarte hoffnung da dass wir zu neuem
wirtschaftswachstum kommen und wir haben
doch vor der pandemie gelernt wenn wir
keine steuern erhöhen nimmt der staat
mehr geld ein weil die wirtschaft
floriert weil viele menschen
beschäftigung haben und weil viele am
ende auch einzahlen und genau daran
müssen wir jetzt anknüpfen
das ist der fundamentale unterschied
zwischen mir und den beiden
mitbewerberinnen und mitbewerber
ich halte den weg über steuererhöhungen
über neue belastung über vermögenssteuer
erbschaftssteuer einkommenssteuer die
linke mit noch ein paar vorschläge mehr
da sie fragen gleich noch
warum das aus ihrer sicht nicht geht
ohne steuererhöhungen ja zunächst mal
muss man dazusagen dass in den
wahlvorschlägen die die union zum
beispiel macht ja die idee steht dass
leute die so viel verdienen wie ein
bundesminister oder noch mehr
steuersenkung bekommen sollen da haben
einige ausgerechnet das dass das dort
vorgeschlagen ist für solche
steuerzahler wie mich und leute die noch
mehr verdienen und für sehr gut
verdienende unternehmen zusammen 30
milliarden euro pro jahr kosten kann und
ich finde das ist unfinanzierbar wir
haben jetzt 400 milliarden euro schulden
gemacht am ende des nächsten jahres wird
es soweit sein und die krise zu
bekämpfen wir haben dafür sorge getragen
dass arbeitsplätze und unternehmen
gerettet werden wer mit der kurzarbeit
über zwei millionen arbeitsplätze
gerettet viel geld für unsere gesundheit
ausgegeben und all das wird nicht gehen
wenn man jetzt sagt die leute die sehr
viel geld verdienen die sollen erstmal
eine steuersenkung bekommen das wird
nicht funktionieren das heißt dass
gegebenenfalls auch die unternehmen und
die unternehmen die sie eigentlich jetzt
brauchen für diese große transformation
das land verlassen das werden sie ja
nicht das ist ja ein ganz ganz großes
gerücht im übrigen haben wir ja im
übrigen sind ein sehr leistungsfähiges
wirtschaftsland das muss man dazu sagen
haben wir gerade einen großen erfolg
errungen wir haben drei jahre lang
verhandelt darüber dass wir eine
weltweite verständigung zustande
bekommen über globale mindestbesteuerung
von unternehmen das ist jetzt erfolgt
das wird in wenigen tagen alles
vollendet werden und dann werden wir
sehen dass der dumping wettbewerb
zwischen den bestatten dass die steuern
immer geringer werden ein ende finden
wird mitgemacht haben länder wie die usa
und großbritannien europa japan wir
werden 134 staaten glauben sie großen
diesen worten von herrn scholz
mit den digital konzern mit dem das ohne
steuererhöhungen selbstverständlich
nicht gehen würde und dass es mit den
steuererhöhungen keine unternehmer aus
dem land treibt
ich halte steuern sind ja kein netzwerk
wenn alles gut wäre da müsste man sagen
wir müssen nichts verändern aber wir
erleben eine situation wo die ärmsten in
unserem land immer ärmer werden und die
reichsten immer reicher plus eine
situation nach corona dass wir in die
krankenhäuser investieren müssen dass
wir in schulen investieren müssen
digitalisierung investieren müssen und
erst recht in klimaschutz und dann
stellt sich ja die frage wenn man das
wirklich machen will und ich will das
machen weil das ist die substanz unseres
landes dann müssen wir das finanzieren
und da gibt es unterschiedliche elemente
das eine ist zb bekämpfung von
steuerbetrug deswegen so richtig dass
digital konzern endlich vernünftig
besteuert werden deswegen will ich
geldwäsche und steuerbetrug so klar
bekämpfen und wir müssen aber auch dafür
sorgen dass wir menschen mit geringen
einkommen entlasten kinder aus der armut
holen und dafür schlage ich als
gegenfinanzierung vor den
einkommenssteuersatz ab 100000 euro
leicht zu erhöhen und das betrifft dann
keine unternehmen deswegen ist es
einfach falsch was sie auch darstellen
den einkommenssteuersatz von menschen
mit viel geld zu erhöhen und dass wir
eine vermögensbesteuerung prüfen damit
wir dafür sorgen dass die länder mehr
geld für die bildung haben weil man kann
sich nicht hinstellen und sagen bildung
ist total wichtig aber das geld stellen
wir dafür nicht bereit und das gehört
für mich zu einer ehrlichen politik dazu
wie hier mal sagen dass das beiden der
grundfehler ist zu glauben wenn man die
wirtschaft abwürgt und steuern erhöht
dass man am ende mehr geld ein
und dass wir nicht in einem
internationalen wettbewerb mehr stehen
auch bei der körperschaftsteuer die
unternehmen zahlen müssen das ist für
einen finanzminister auch eine
erstaunliche aussage denn natürlich
überlegen unternehmen so investieren wir
auch innerhalb der europäischen union
und wenn wir dann viele vorschriften
viel bürokratie es immer komplizierter
machen und dazu noch die steuern erhöhen
wird dass arbeitsplätze in unserem land
gefährden und bei der vermögenssteuer
weiß jeder was heißt das denn auf
deutsch es gibt ein vermögen was jemand
besitzt und dann kommt der finanzbeamte
und beginnt das zu errechnen das
aktienpaket das sparbuch das geht ja nur
einfach aber den schreibtisch oder das
bild an der wand oder dieses und jenes
und weil es so kompliziert es hat das
verfassungsgericht gesagt das ist nicht
gerecht machbar wie es bisher gemacht
hat die regierung von gerhard schröder
hat deshalb keine vermögenssteuer unter
ihrer beteiligung mehr erhoben weil es
ein so riesiger bürokratischer aufwand
ist wenn der in jedem fall nach vorne
geguckt und jetzt kommt dieses wieder
aus der kiste
svenja lassen hier warum wollen sie die
aus der kiste sehen her scholz kurze
antwort das ist ja schon gesagt haben
wir müssen was tun für die bildung es
geht um einnahmen für die länder wir
haben diese steuer gehabt über viele
viele jahre und jahrhunderte tatsächlich
ist sie erhoben worden sie ist noch in
der ganzen regierungszeit von herrn kohl
erhoben worden es ist das ganze
wirtschaftswunder in deutschland mit
dieser steuer möglich gewesen spricht
also wenig dagegen wenn wir jetzt etwas
mehr geld für bildung und polizei in den
ländern haben dass das für unsere
wirtschaft schlecht wäre aber mir ist
noch ein hinweis wichtig bei der
diskussion über globale verständigung
zur besteuerung die ich eben geschildert
habe die uns ja hilft als land weil wir
nicht mehr diesen druck ausgesetzt sind
kommt ja auch heraus dass viele länder
von denen man das gar nicht gedacht hat
jetzt darüber nachdenken ihre steuern
sogar anzuheben was für
unternehmenssteuern keiner von uns vor
schlecht wenn ich das richtig sehe also
zum beispiel sind die bis großbritannien
dabei hat das zu machen die konservative
regierung die usa diskutieren das gerade
mit ihrem parlament der präsident biden
hat das vorgeschlagen wenn wir unseren
guten moderaten weg weitergehen dann
können wir unser land finanzieren aber
es wird nicht gehen mit steuergeschenken
für leuten die sehr sehr viel geld
verdienen das an zusammenhalt zustande
zu bringen was wir brauchen und die
investitionen zu finanzieren die wir für
die zukunft dass
ein punkt und schauen es noch einmal die
zeiten an die tatsächlich relativ nahe
beieinander sind mit einem kleinen
vorsprung aber
den werden wir jetzt nicht mehr komplett
ausgeglichen kriegen denn wir kommen zu
dem schluss gekommen schon zu den
schluss statements die reihenfolge haben
sie vorher ausgelost untereinander es
wird beginnen mit jetzt nochmal einem
einminütigen
vortrag am laschet
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wir
drei haben jetzt 90 minuten diskutiert
aber es geht nicht um uns es geht um sie
es geht um vertrauen ich vertraue
unserem land unseren arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmern den unternehmern den
gewerkschaften den forscherinnen und
wissenschaftlern dass sie unser land
stark machen können
ich garantiere ihnen
als bundeskanzler sie können mir
vertrauen das ich bürokratie abschaffe
dass ich nicht gängeln dass ich sie
machen lasse dass wir ihnen nicht
vorschreiben
wie sie zu denken haben und wie sie zu
reden haben und wie sie zu leben haben
und so können wir es gemeinsam schaffen
ein klimaneutrales industrieland zu
werden ein land wirtschaftlich stark
sozial
und sicher dafür steht die union dafür
will ich als bundeskanzler arbeiten will
ein bundeskanzler des vertrauens werden
und darauf für bitte ich um ihr
vertrauen vielen dank und als nächste
ist annalena baerbock an der reihe
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer sie
haben die wahl schaffen wir einen echten
aufbruch oder verharren wir im weiter so
die nächste regierung ist die letzte die
noch aktiv einfluss auf die klimakrise
nehmen kann und ich bin zutiefst davon
überzeugt wir können das das ist eine
riesenchance für unser land für ein
gesundes und gutes leben für eine starke
wirtschaft mit sicheren arbeitsplätzen
für einen echten sozialen zusammenhalt
das ist die aufgabe unserer zeit die
aufgabe meiner generation
unsere kinder unsere enkel sondern sich
fragen müssen warum habt ihr nichts
getan sondern wie habt ihr das geschafft
dafür trete ich an als ihre
kanzlerkandidaten dafür stehen wir grün
für eine moderne regierung die handelt
bevor es zu spät ist sie entscheiden
deutschland kann so viel mehr
dank an annalena baerbock olaf scholz
mit seinem schlussstatement
es ist jetzt eine entscheidung über die
zukunft deutschlands zu treffen und wir
haben gesehen was unser land kann
solidarität haben wir gezeigt bei der
bekämpfung der korona krise solidarität
haben mehr
zustande gebracht jetzt wo es darum geht
den zu helfen die opfer der flut
geworden sind in nordrhein-westfalen
rheinland-pfalz und einigen anderen
landstrichen unseres landes und diese
solidarität dieser zusammenhalt das
brauchen wir auch für die zukunft
deshalb setze ich mich dafür ein dass in
dieser gesellschaft wieder mehr respekt
herrscht respekt vorleben und vor jeder
dass wir dafür sorgen dass jede
berufliche leistung dass jede
lebensleistung anerkannt wird nicht nur
während der kroner krise sondern auch
danach und das heißt auch dass
diejenigen die heute wenig verdienen
besser bezahlt werden müssen dass wir
einen mindestlohn von 12 euro bekommen
und stabile renten die es gibt wenn man
für die sozialdemokratische partei
stimmt und gleichzeitig geht es um
deutschlands industrielle zukunft ob wir
jetzt ganz schnell im nächsten jahr alle
notwendigen entscheidungen treffen damit
deutschland die wirtschaftliche kraft
entfaltet auch in zehn 20 30 jahren noch
gute arbeitsplätze zu haben und damit
wir gleichzeitig den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufhalten können große
aufgaben zu denen unser land aber fähig
ist ich möchte ihnen dafür als
bundeskanzler dienen und bitte sie
deshalb um die stimme für die
sozialdemokratische partei
dank an olaf scholz und nun überhaupt
den drei kandidaten und kandidatinnen
für diese sendung heute abend ihnen
danken wir für ihre aufmerksamkeit liebe
zuschauer es geht natürlich im programm
weiter und wer von den zuschauerinnen
und zuschauern am meisten von der einen
oder dem anderen überzeugt worden ist
das erfahren sie bei ard und zdf jetzt
direkt im anschluss da gibt es nämlich
nicht nur analysen sondern auch
blitzumfragen und ergebnisse zu eben
dieser frage das war es von uns einen
schönen abend vielen dank nochmal und
sie bleiben bitte schön gesund und sie
gehen wählen in 14 tagen
und sie erfahren es natürlich auch bei
phoenix
sollte man noch dazu sagen und ich
möchte einfach so schnell wie möglich zu
erhard scherfer nach berlin schalten
denn er ist vor ort er hat es
unmittelbar verfolgt und ich bin sehr
gespannt erhard scherfer wie der
eindruck bei ihnen ist war es diesmal
bissiger was schneller was konkret was
spannender als das erste drittel
naja zumindest die ersten 20 minuten die
haben ja einiges hergegeben als es um
diverse themen gegen die mit dem
bundesfinanzminister und vizekanzler zu
tun hatten da konnte man hier auch sehr
schön die unterschiedlichen reaktionen
beobachten links hinter mir
beispielsweise war ein relativ großer
grüner blog wenn ich den mal so nennen
darf und rechts hinter mir war ein
relativ gut ausgeprägte spd blog die
christdemokraten und christsozialen die
mitglieder und die anhänger die haben
sich nach draußen begeben die haben vor
diesem zelt gesessen und dieses trio von
draußen sich betrachtet da hörte man
gelegentlich dann auch mal den applaus
hier wir sehen das zelt rein brannten
aber man muss sagen dass zumindest ein
großer teil dieser veranstaltung doch
sehr zivilisiert aus meiner sicht über
die bühne gegangen ist so man sehr
bemüht war argumente auszutauschen und
es dann auch nicht mehr so giftig war
wie in den ersten 20 minuten aber ich
kann diese frage gleich weiter geben ich
freue mich dass marian laut uns gekommen
ist aus der parlamentsredaktion der zeit
was ist ihr eindruck der gesamteindruck
von diesem zweiten trial in diesem
ich fand das war ne sehr
zivilisiert
inhalts starke
diskussion auch wenn es ein bisschen
gedauert hat bis man so in gang gekommen
ist sie hat das gefühl sie hat so ein
bisschen die sache verlangsamt das am
anfang sehr viel von koalitionen die
rede war und von dem gespenst das nicht
mit am tisch saß der linkspartei die
nicht relevant genug ist um am tisch zu
sitzen und trotzdem ebenso lange thema
davon abgesehen fand ich war ich
wirklich froh dass er jetzt endlich mal
so themen wie rente
auf dem kaffee waren
wo man sich fragt wo ist dieses thema zb
eigentlich im wahlkampf und das war
jetzt da und das fand ich schon ziemlich
gut wenn es jetzt insgesamt wird das
gespräch geführt worden ist auch wie die
kandidaten kandidatinnen kandidaten sich
untereinander ausgetauscht und
diskutiert haben also ich finde man hat
gemerkt dass olaf scholz durch diese
konkreten anwürfe jetzt so ein bisschen
aus diesem präsidialen und so bisschen
über dem wasser schwebenden aus dieser
rolle so ein bisschen rausgekitzelt
worden ist und ein bisschen aus der
reserve geraten ist annalena baerbock
war
wieder sehr offensiv und am anfang war
die lustige diskussion situation dass
laschet und baerbock zusammen sozusagen
denn olaf scholz konfrontiert haben und
ist der ist dadurch auch tatsächlich
irritiert worden also das war
interessant und neu bei armin laschet
fand ich wie ich überhaupt finde dass er
so in den letzten tagen einfach sehr
viel schärfer angreift es hat sich dann
so ein bisschen manchmal verletzt was er
jetzt so konkret meinte man merkt
einfach dass annalena baerbock nicht an
der regierung ist und nicht in der
schwierigen situation ist eben das
verteidigen zu müssen was sie eigentlich
nicht verteilen und umgekehrt da durch
die lücken nutzen konnte die die anderen
aus ihrer sicht haben in den vergangenen
jahren hinterlassen so ist es genau
jetzt schon ein bisschen einzelkritik
das wäre gleich vielleicht noch mal ein
kleines bisschen auch vertiefen ich
meine so insgesamt der austausch unter
unter den drei die art und weise wie die
drei miteinander diskutiert haben und
gestritten es war ja ein bisschen
ausgeprägter als bei dem trial dass wir
vor 14 tagen gesehen haben genau also
ganz genau ich finde es war zwar
kontroverse aber gleichzeitig fand ich
dass es themen gab auf die alle nicht so
wirklich geantwortet haben nämlich die
frage wie viel teurer wird eigentlich
für den einzelnen der klimawandel bzw
die bewältigung das ist so eine frage da
sind alle parteien so ein bisschen auf
zehenspitzen
unterwegs und genauso teilweise gar
nicht so wirklich sagen kann oder weil
es ja auch davon abhängen welche
kombination dann nach der wahl zustande
kommen sie spielt ja auch eine große
rolle welche koalitions dann geben wird
und welche mittel und welche maßnahmen
ergriffen werden ja absolut ist ja auch
immer so ein bisschen im ungefähren
natürlich total ist es ja ich glaube so
offen wie sie hätten was jetzt passieren
wird wirklich also wir journalisten
fahren glaube ich auch alle aufsicht
weil einfach jede prognose jede analyse
in einer woche schon absolut überholt
sein kann und unser 1 von der
wochenzeitung hat damit natürlich ein
kleines problem
genau aber also dass diese themen die
renten und klima und so was wird sich
für mich ändern da blieb die runde so
ein bisschen im ungefähren vielleicht
war es auch ganz anders geht es wird ja
immer gefragt als solchen runden herzen
sieger oder eine siegerin gegeben was
ist denn ihre sie ist nicht also ist
nicht mein eindruck es gab weder irgend
einen totalausfall noch einen klaren
sieger meiner ansicht nach ich
persönlich fand annalena baerbock am
klarsten aber aus dem bekannten grund
dass man sie am entspanntesten war und
einfach so angriffslustig aber aber
schon sehr sortiert und so während bei
den anderen fand ich dass die sich sehr
leicht mal verhaspelt da haben wir in
irgendwelchen details aber wie gesagt
ich glaube das hängt auch damit zusammen
dass sie halt nicht eine regierung zu
verantworten hat weil sie vielleicht
inzwischen auch weiß dass ihre chancen
kanzlerin zu werden doch deutlich
geringer sind als so reden dieses
wahlkampfs und da kann man natürlich
vielleicht auch etwas anders so ist eine
solche debatte rand während die beiden
anderen ja immer noch darum ringen
tatsächlich werden sie sich regierung
einzuführen und die chancen ja auch
tatsächlich noch da sind sie haben
themen am anfang auch schon mal
angesprochen haben sagte jetzt wurde
auch mal über pflege diskutiert und über
das wohnen und und solche solche dinge
gibt es bereiche wo sie sagen sie sind
auch heute wieder auf der strecke
geblieben mir ist aufgefallen dass die
außenpolitik im grunde keine rolle
geschrieben hat und das vor dem
hintergrund dass wir vor noch nicht
einmal 14 tagen eine massive und
intensive diskussion beispielsweise
hatten über den einsatz in afghanistan
ja die außenpolitik war komplett irre
und für die runde das ist mir auch
aufgefallen
das wäre mit sicherheit anders gewesen
weil die linkspartei mit am tisch
gesessen hätte
aber trotzdem natürlich so was wie
humanitäre interventionen oder wie wird
man künftig mit der regierung tut dienen
sich stellen oder so das hätte mich von
olaf scholz mal sehr interessiert und
wie er das eigentlich sieht da sind ja
viele sozialdemokraten immer noch sehr
auf wandel durch annäherung und so das
ist mir auch aufgefallen ist komplett
ausgespart werden praktisch ganz ganz
kurz zum schluss gibt es eine chance
dass das wählerverhalten beeinflusst hat
dieses trio
würde mich sehr wundern aber es ist
natürlich immer möglich mariam lau
vielen dank dass sie so schnell bei uns
gewesen sind nach dieser runde wir
können ihnen gerade noch sagen dass das
eigentliche spinnen dr -ing das
beeinflussen wenn hier tatsächlich doch
oder auch vielleicht doch eher einer von
den dreien gewonnen hat diese
auseinandersetzung diese diese verbale
gerade draußen im hof stattfindet
deswegen ist es hier in dem zelt gerade
wieder relativ leer aber draußen sind
jetzt die aktiv über die wir um 20 uhr
schon gesprochen haben also wie berater
die pressesprecher und alle die dazu
gehören und auch jede menge
politikerinnen und politiker die
versuchen jetzt wahrscheinlich auch uns
kolleginnen und kollegen da draußen zu
erklären ob ihr tatsächlich doch eine
oder eine die nase vorn gehabt hat wir
melden uns nachher nochmal erstmal so
thomas bade zurückfielen dank erhard
scherfer willkommen tatsächlich gleich
noch mal zu ihnen zurück aber die
umfragen von denen sie gesprochen haben
die da draußen auf dem hof stattgefunden
haben da gibt es jetzt tatsächlich sogar
erste zahlen die wir soeben bekommen
haben und diese ersten zahlen sagen uns
dass 39 prozent von scholz am meisten
überzeugt waren 25 prozent von frau bär
bock und 24 prozent von herrn laschet
volker kronenberg politikwissenschaftler
bei mir im studio deckt sich das mit
ihrer beobachtung
vielleicht ganz grundsätzlich solche
momentaufnahmen und solche zahlen sind
immer mit sehr viel vorsicht eben auch
zu genießen
darauf kann man nicht allzu viel lesen
ich möchte es mal so sagen
es hat mich denen einen klaren sieger
gegeben oder die eine persönlichkeit die
sozusagen eklatant abgefallen ist aber
doch auffällig war sicherlich und das
kann man ja positiv wie negativ sehen
dass wir heute doch einen sehr
prägnanten offensiven und auch klaren
armin laschet erlebt haben das ist ja
gerade im gespräch auch angedeutet
worden in den ersten 20 minuten ging es
ja sehr turbulent hoch her und meine
wahrnehmung war dass olaf scholz
zumindest in der ersten hälfte der
sendungen oder womöglich auch die ganze
sendung durch er sozusagen aus dieser
erfahrung heraus ein stückweit
defensiver eben aufgetreten ist
wohingegen dann die dritte im bunde die
gelöste dritte würde ich fast sagen
tatsächlich ja auch die protagonistin
einer partei die nicht in
regierungsverantwortung ist frisch
offensiv gelöst eben auftritt vielleicht
eben auch angesichts der tatsache dass
sie nicht mehr um platz eins kämpft die
beiden herren haben sich im grunde
nichts
geschenkt aber das was man armin laschet
über lange zeit nachgesagt hat dass er
nicht klar genug ist nicht offensiv
genug jetzt nicht leidenschaftlich genug
aufgetreten ist das wird mir nehmen
heute sicherlich nicht zum vorwurf
machen können was wir eben im ersten
feedback ja auch gehört haben war dass
die außenpolitik so gar keine rolle
gespielt hat und das natürlich auch
vermisst wurde warum glauben sie ist das
so na ja das ist natürlich ein missstand
das muss man ganz klar so sagen es geht
hier um die nächsten vier jahre es geht
um die leitlinien der bundesdeutschen
politik europa kam immer mal wieder
übrigens ja nur ihn antworten nicht in
den fragen zur rede und das ist
natürlich notwendig was ist die lehrer
aus corona und dann hat man den blick zu
recht auch auf europa gewarnt das ist so
ein stück hat typisch
bundesrepublikanische politische kultur
natürlich auch über viele jahre und
jahrzehnte sehr stark auf die
innenpolitik fokussiert naja wenn dann
europa aber außenpolitik dann weniger
verteidigung und sicherheitspolitik und
das ist natürlich umso erstaunlicher vor
dem hintergrund eben der erfahrung die
wir jetzt vor wenigen tagen und wochen
in afghanistan gemacht haben den
ereignissen in den vereinigten staaten
und und und andere mehr der diskussion
um verteidigung das ist tatsächlich ein
monitor es wird ja eine dritte runde
geben und ich wage die prognose dass man
hier sicherlich den blick auf außen
sicherheit verteidigung und europa
richten muss das gehört ganz wesentlich
zu den ganz grundlegenden politischen
fragen dieses landes der zukunft der
nächsten 4 18 jahren natürlich dazu wir
sind gespannt und warten darauf
professor kronberg wir sprechen gleich
nochmal aber ich würde gerne noch einmal
zu meinem kollegen erhard schäfer nach
berlin gehen denn sie haben noch einen
gast sie haben eva quadbeck zu gast bei
sich
so ist das die stellvertretende
chefredakteurin des redaktions netzwerk
deutschland und leiterin des berliner
büros ist bei uns eva quadbeck ich habe
von mariam lau auch schon ganz allgemein
und ganz offen gefragt was ist ihr
eindruck von diesem oder ihr
gesamteindruck von diesem trio
also man konnte gut merken dass die
atmosphäre im wahlkampf schärfer
geworden ist aggressiver geworden ist
das war sehr viel mehr schlagabtausch
als bei dem ersten tv duell was wir
sehen konnten man ist sich mehr ins wort
gefallen man muss auch sagen dass die
moderatoren durchaus die sache mit ihren
fragen auch entsprechend getrieben haben
und sind es ganz klar geworden dass wir
auf der einen seite laschet hätten und
auf der anderen seite in starken
schulterschluss von rot grün vor allem
die ersten 20 minuten hat es
insbesondere um olaf scholz und das
finanzministerium
diverse finanzskandale in den
vergangenen jahren gingen da war doch
richtig gut was los richtig und das gute
daran war dass sich in diesen vielen
dingen diesen ersten 20 minuten nicht so
durch merken konnte wie er das eben beim
letzten mal gemacht hat da war im grunde
genommen die wort gewordene laute der
kanzlerin und das hat diesmal nicht
funktioniert nein jetzt richtig unter
druck gewesen er musste sich verteidigen
ja war in der defensive hat dann aber
sehr schnell wieder in seine rolle
gefunden und ist dann auch wieder
staatsmännisch aufgetreten so wie es
vorher zu erwarten war wer wäre jetzt
meine nachfrage auch gewesen auch
speziell auf dieses erste themenfeld
bezogene baby hat er sich denn da
geschlagen ihr habt das auch so gesehen
dass er da in der defensive war hat er
sich ihrer meinung nach der ordentlichen
wieder raus auch bei diesem thema
ordentlich raus ging nicht
ausdiskutiert sagen das war für ihn auf
jeden fall die schwierigste phase der
sendung er war nicht ganz überzeugend
und an einer stelle hat laschet ihn auch
bekommen indem man eben erklärt hat dass
immer wieder um stolz herum die aufsicht
versagt hat und das war ja wirklich das
ist ja eine linie was man sehen kann bei
allen drei fällen bei comex bei wirecard
und jetzt auch bei dieser neuen behörde
bei dieser behörde wo es um geldwäsche
geht und um den kampf gegen geldwäsche
das wieder aufsicht versagt hat das ist
durchaus ein scheiß hängen geblieben
haben ihn lehrte war vor dieser auch vor
diesem trailer vor diesem wochenende
massiv unter druck gesetzt worden vor
allem aus den reihen der csu man hat von
ihm verlangt dass er hier angreift dass
es auch an diesem wochenende
auch ihm gelingt irgendwie eine
trendwende hin zu legen ist das gelungen
aus ihrer sicht armin laschet was er
besser gemacht hat als beim letzten mal
er wirkte nicht so übellaunig sondern
und er hat sich nicht zu sehr auf
scholz' bezogen sondern er hat mehr
seine eigene performance gemacht auch
immer wieder die eine oder andere karte
gezogen themen die er sich vorbereitet
hatte und dann versucht seine punkte zu
setzen ich sehe aber nicht dass wir die
trendwende einladen leighton konnte
warum nicht generell war das einfach der
der pfad jetzt schon so verloren ist ja
weil dafür auch zu eindeutig war dass es
auf der einen seite gab es noch
auseinandersetzungen zwischen scholz und
lasche die beiden sind ja immer wieder
in den schlagabtausch gegangen was dann
auch dazu führte dass die grünen
kanzlerkandidaten die durchaus stark war
aber trotzdem wenn man so ein bisschen
am rand stand und diese schlagabtausche
jetzt einmal abgesehen davon von diesen
ersten 20 minuten als es um die
finanzskandale gingen die gegen doch
punkt punktemäßig er an scholz und dann
hat scholz eben und bernburg auch immer
wieder diesen rot grünen schulterschluss
gemacht das heißt stolz stand am ende
als einfach der stärkere da deshalb
glaube ich dass es nicht gelungen ist
die trendwende einzuleiten aber über
zwei kandidaten schon mal separat
gesprochen sie haben anna lena berbalk
eben auch angesprochen mein eindruck ist
dass sie seit ist relativ klar ist dass
sie wahrscheinlich nicht bundeskanzlerin
wird entspannter auftritt auch gelöster
dadurch auch zugewandter wirkt sie hat
ja heute zweimal auch beispielsweise auf
die stehende oder weiterlaufende uhr von
olaf scholz verwiesen hatte am anfang
die technische panne die wir im
hintergrund nur gehört haben also
irgendwie etwas umgefallen ist auch
gleich mal mit moderiert wie ist ihr
eindruck insgesamt von mir von
beziehungsweise wie hat sich in
anführungszeichen verkauf bei diesem
trio sie war tabs und sie war souverän
und sie war sachlich sattelfest sie
konnte immer wieder ihre
programmatischen punkte machen sie war
auch schlagfertig und trotzdem kann man
nicht sagen sie seit siegerin
hervorgegangen weil so eindeutig war wie
dann am ende doch auch die konstellation
ist und natürlich man im hinterkopf hat
wie die umfragewerte sind und ja sie war
sie war locker sie war richtig gut und
trotzdem ist er aber nicht die siegerin
des abends sondern sie war eigentlich
mehr der joker und ganz stark fand ich
die situation in der sie dann erstmal
sich den schlagabtausch zum thema klima
der beiden herren angehört hat und dann
hinterher gesagt hat ja wie schön ihre
vergangenheitsbewältigung hat ja nun
gezeigt warum wir beim klima nicht
vorangekommen sind das waren so ganz
starke momente nichtsdestotrotz
wird sie das nicht unbedingt weiter
bringen was das thema kanzleramt angeht
mit einschätzung des zweiten teils
demnächst gibt es ja noch ein drittes
bei der prosieben gruppe insgesamt sie
müssen jetzt ein kommentar schreiben
viel erfolg und gutes gelingen damit und
wir beobachten hier noch ein klein wenig
wieder draußen weiter gespannt ob dort
wird geben aber ansonsten zurück zu
thomas bade erhard scherfer vielen dank
und das wird noch spannend in dieser
nacht in den nächsten tagen weil
natürlich jetzt alle seiten versuchen
werden dass zu ihren gunsten zu
interpretieren und deshalb ist es
vielleicht ganz schön wenn wir an dieser
stelle die letzte aktuellste umfrage
seriöse umfrage in deutschland ihnen
noch einmal zeigen wenn am nächsten
sonntag bundestagswahl wäre
dann kämen cdu csu auf 22 prozent die
spd könnte mit 25 prozent rechnen die
afg käme auf elf prozent die fdp
ebenfalls auf elf prozent die linke auf
6 prozent die grünen auf 17
die freien wähler auf drei prozent und
die anderen parteien zusammen auf 5
prozent aber darunter ist keine partei
die mindestens drei prozent erreichen
würde das also die aktuellste
existierende umfrage volker kronenberg
unsere aufgabe jetzt zum schluss der
übertragung dieses tri ace doch noch
einmal ja eine gewichtung vielleicht
vorzunehmen wie wichtig war diese strell
für die letzten zwei wochen des
bundestagswahlkampfs
und glauben sie dass das heute noch mal
was bewirkt hat dass sich die zahlen die
wir eben gehört haben vielleicht in der
nächsten sonntagsfrage dadurch ändern
da beide das ist ein wichtiges element
hält diese diese zusammenkünfte ob jetzt
duell tree l das gehört zum wahlkampf
heute dazu das wird von vielen
zuschauern zuschauern zur kenntnis
genommen es wird darüber diskutiert
haben selbst gesagt diese nacht morgen
in den kommenden tagen das gehört auch
zur heißen wahlkampfphase in den letzten
wochen dazu wie variieren das seit
monaten und das zeigen ja auch die
erfahrungen gerade wenn es immer näher
auf den wahltermin zukommt dann
entscheiden sich immer noch ein großteil
der menschen ob sie wählen gehen und wen
sie wählen die zahlen auch die
sonntagsfrage oder jetzt die ersten
umfrage wer über gewinne wer verlierer
die zahlen sind im fluss sie sind
volatil sagen mir sie können sich so
oder so auch entwickeln binnen weniger
tage sie geben natürlich ein trend aber
es ist natürlich auch klar dass binnen
zwei wochen sich noch etwas verändern
kann für mich aufschlussreich heute
abend war jetzt gerade auch durch
ebenfall quadbeck es war vom rot grünen
schulterschluss die rede ich glaube zwei
punkte sind auch heute abend darum
lichte dieser zahlen nicht ganz zu
vernachlässigen es kommt ganz wesentlich
nicht nur auf rot und grün die grünen an
sondern sicherlich auch auf die fdp von
der heute abend nicht ganz so viel die
rede war weil natürlich ganz klar diese
zahlen indizieren dass ein zweierbündnis
sehr schwierig werden wird es wird auf
drei ankommen und da wird es auch auf
die fdp kommen das war übrigens auch
einer der adressaten von armin laschet
wenn er sagt mehr selbstentfaltung mehr
freiheit mehr eigenverantwortung weniger
gesetze weniger staat das war klar an
die adresse der fdp gerichtet
und das andere ist eben die tatsache
dass sozusagen hier eben auch nicht
derjenige der im zweifelsfalle hauchdünn
die nase vorne hat unbedingt derjenige
sein wird der ins kanzleramt einzieht
wir haben zwei mal in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik auch erlebt das ist
fulminante wahlsiege gab der union 1976
und 1980 und letztendlich ein
sozialdemokrat kanzler blieb mit hilfe
der fdp das könnte sich auch umkehren
also insofern es kommt nicht nur darauf
an wer auf platz eins liegt sondern in
dem es nachher am ende gelingt sozusagen
ein womöglich dreier bündnis zu
schmieden ich will darauf hinaus ist
auch in den letzten 14 tagen doch noch
einiges möglich noch ist nicht alles
entschieden und spannend ist ja auch
platz 3 uns jetzt mal so zu nennen wir
haben festgestellt während der debatte
heute dass sowohl armin laschet als auch
olaf scholz phasenweise doch ziemlich
angespannt waren aber annalena baerbock
eigentlich sehr relaxed und sehr
kämpferisch und sehr tochter
reingegangen ist und letztlich ist sie
möglicherweise ja für beide eine
interessante koalitionspartnerin und
wird sich vielleicht zwischen diesen
beiden männern entscheiden können
erwartet zweifellos das ist sie und wir
wissen ja auch das ist jetzt nicht nur
die person baerbock da kommt er habe da
kommen die grünen in ihrer entwicklung
der letzten jahre da kommen schwarz
grüne und grünen schwarze bündnisse auf
länderebene dazu natürlich würde frau
berg natürlich würden die grünen auch
wenn es drauf ankäme und wenn das
angebot stimmt das gesamtpaket auch eine
jamaika-koalition mit schwarz und gelb
eingehen klar heute eine größere nähe
grundsätzlich in wichtigen
politikfeldern sicherlich zur spd aber
das sollte man verweis auf christian
lindner in dieser konstellation
sozusagen nicht der lachende dritte aber
der wichtige dritte natürlich bedeuten
es geht ja nicht nur um rot grün und wie
nah man sich da ist sondern da wird
christian lindner wird die fdp natürlich
ein gehöriges wörtchen mitreden von
daher gesehen
koalitionspolitisch und deswegen war
auch die platzierung von frau bär bock
in der mitte sehr klug
koalitionspolitisch anschlussfähig wäre
sie zu beiden parteien zu beiden
möglichen kanzlern womit wir sozusagen
am ende unseres gesprächs wieder beim
anfang des trends während da wurde ja
auch über koalitionen schon geredet ohne
dass das eigentlich wirklich an stand in
diesem moment welche halten sie für am
wahrscheinlichsten
natürlich die entscheidende frage sie
haben gesagt es kann sich noch viel tun
insofern mag ich mich nicht festlegen
aber vielleicht doch noch einen verweis
jetzt haben wir grün gelb gesprochen und
dann kennen wir zurück zum eingang
schreiben sozusagen zwischen laschet und
scholz es geht natürlich auch um die
linkspartei weil das ist natürlich dann
die andere koalitionsoptionen rot grün
rot oder es war auch mal grün rot rot
das im übrigen aber herr bade sicherlich
ein punkt die ihnen die union in den
letzten verbleibenden tagen noch einmal
sehr offensiv gegen herrn scholz wird
anführen wollen und an dieser stelle
wirkte er heute doch auffallend in der
defensive denn scholz weiß natürlich
sehr genau er persönlich wird das nicht
favorisieren aber fresken walter borjans
und andere liebäugeln natürlich schon
sehr lange mit einer solchen
koalitionsoption insofern tut sich hier
natürlich für die spd ein spalt auf und
scholz wird alles daran setzen das ist
hier nicht weiter sozusagen zu einem
anheizen dieser koalitionsdebatte kommt
und da sind wir im grunde dann am anfang
der debatte wieder angekommen heute und
damit schließt sich der kreis für heute
professor volker kronenberg vielen dank
für das gespräch für ihre anordnungen
gern dank dass sie von der bonner uni zu
uns ins studio gekommen sind halt gerne
und für sie geht es natürlich weiter
jetzt gleich bei phoenix morgen um 9 uhr
früh übrigens mit der nächsten sage ich
mal
informationssendung mit der nächsten vor
ort sendung und sicherlich auch weiteren
analysen zu diesem heutigen abend zur
symmetrie l aber jetzt gleich ist glaube
ich mal zeit für ein bisschen
entspannung und für eine reise und es
ist ein schöner aussicht jetzt auf den
pazifik zu gehen gute nacht
[Musik]